True, lul weh.
So.
Ja, wird mal wieder Zeit.
Also.
Leute, ich muss euch mal was sagen.
Irgendwie,
ich weiß nicht,
woran es liegt, keine Ahnung,
mir tut unten links
ein bisschen der Zahn weh.
Ich hab keine Ahnung warum.
Also man sieht auch nix.
Und da hab ich mir gedacht, ey,
weißt du was,
bevor du da jetzt lang rumfackelst,
rufst mal deinen Zahnarzt an,
lässt einfach mal gucken.
Ja, vielleicht muss man einfach nur ein bisschen
Zahnstein wegmachen oder so, keine Ahnung.
Und dann hab ich geguckt und hab festgestellt,
der hat um 12 Uhr
zugemacht.
Ja, aber es ist auch noch so extrem
schlimm ist es jetzt grad nicht.
Es ist auch schon wieder besser, vielleicht nehmen wir auch was an Zahnfleisch
oder so, aber es ist nervig auf jeden Fall.
Das Ätzende
an so Zahngeschichten oder generell
Sachen im Mund ist ja,
dass, ähm,
das gar nicht so extrem weh tut, aber das ist halt
so permanent immer mal wieder und das geht halt,
das nervt halt ultra, ne.
Das ist halt huge.
Sack, Alter.
Huge Gym, 16 Monate, huge,
keine, kein Couchtreme, ich bin so müde heute,
ich bin so kaputt, das krieg ich nicht hin.
Aber für die Call of Duty Fans gibt's einmal
so, ähm,
ja, Huge Gym, 12, äh,
16, 16 Monate, ist übelst hier.
Massive.
Nice Subscription.
Das ist ja quasi schon, wo hab ich's?
Das neue Call of Duty,
naja, ich war ja dumm.
Ich hab's vorbestellt.
Richtig, also, ich hab's, nein, das ist vorbestellt.
Ich hab's quasi
vorbestellt, dass ich die Alpha spielen könnte.
Und, äh,
jetzt hab ich's halt. Ich hab's noch nicht installiert.
Ich hab extra geguckt, ob es
irgendwelche G2A gibt. Übrigens, wisst ihr, was wir
jetzt mal zusammen nachgucken? Moment, ich mach mal die Musik
ein bisschen leiser, bisschen lauter.
Ein bisschen, ein bisschen,
ein bisschen aggressive, die Musik hier.
Oh, übrigens, ich, wisst ihr was?
Ich muss meinen Sound wieder einstellen.
Ich hör mich bestimmt total
übersteuert an. Das liegt daran, weil
Teams mal wieder,
ja, guckt's euch an, Teams hat mal wieder
meinen Sound umgestellt.
Das ist unglaublich fail, dieses Programm.
So dermaßen scheiße.
Und ich kann nichts
dagegen machen. Es gibt noch nicht mal eine Option
dafür, dass man das umstellt.
Nee, man kann das nicht
umstellen. Wenn man das pre-ordert, das hat sich
hier Activision gedacht, wenn man das pre-ordert,
dann kannst du es nicht wieder abbestellen.
Die haben sich gedacht, true, lul weh,
Kokomrit, Leute, jetzt habt ihr gelitten.
Jetzt müsst ihr hier, jetzt wisst ihr, ob ihr wollt
oder nicht. Teams macht es halt so, damit es für
DAOs gut funktioniert. Ja, schon, aber man könnte
trotzdem eine Option einbauen. Bitte nicht das
Mikrofon des Systems anfassen. Das wäre ja eine
Möglichkeit, ne? Also Bang gut aufmachen.
Exzellent beste, beste, besser Seite.
Name Ich finde, ich kann also ich kann
mittlerweile verstehen, warum es so weh, warum
es viele Leute gibt, die nicht gerne bei China
Seiten bestellen. Weil wenn guckt euch mal diese
Seite an, also objektiv betrachtet sieht die nicht
sonderlich vertrauenserweckend aus, oder?
Das sieht aus wie eine Scammer Fishing Seite.
Die sieht übelst Scammer aus.
die seite aliexpress ist auch nicht viel besser aber aber ein bisschen besser
bald ist die elfte elfte zugabe ist klar die elfte elfte zugabe die brauche ja
auch schon immer was ist denn die elfte elfte zugabe eine zahnbürste ja ja das
verbinde ich eindeutig mit elfte elfter zugabe ganz klar was sonst ich denke
weil ja auch chat eine million dings gewinnen easy easy money ja man muss
schon mal ehrlich sagen so wahnsinnig vertrauens erwecken sie die seite jetzt
nicht aus die seite sie einfach fast leider ich finde aliexpress ist nicht
ganz so voll geklatscht man erkennt schon einiges ähnlich ja aber aber ich
meine banggood ist wer auch wer auch halbwegs halbwegs geht ist gearbest die
spammen nicht ganz so rum wobei man sagen muss
ich habe das gefühl diese ganzen asia shop seiten die haben alle einen designer
das sieht schon relativ wenig aus dass wahrscheinlich das staatliche
ministerium für webseiten shop design oder so und das macht es halt überall
die anderen einen wordpress eine wordpress vorlage und die wird dann
leicht angepasst die gibt es auch noch genau die gibt es ja auch noch die habe
ich die vergesse ich immer da bestelle ich so wenig da bestelle ich so wie die
vergesse ich immer wieder exzellent das brauche ich jetzt also natürlich die
hose ja klar
ja chat ich wollte irgendwas sagen aber ich hab's jetzt voll verdrängt also ich
wollte die musik leiser waren vielleicht ist das nicht ja aber ob ich doch ich
glaube verhältnis stimme musik ist okay so ne wish wish also wish das also das
kann ich nicht verstehen wie man da wie man das bestellt weil wish ist quasi
china in scheiße
so gemacht dass es auch nubs bestellen können also das ist quasi das ist quasi
alles was schlecht an china ist so gemacht dass es kack nubs bestellen
können also wish ist totaler rotz also also das kann ich nicht verstehen wie
wir haben uns ja letztes mal ein fake account of wish gemacht um zu gucken was
es da so gibt das ist wirklich einfach nur aliexpress und banggood in schlecht
aber halt so dass die leute denken sie bestellen irgendwie aus deutschland oder
sonstwo
und dabei ist das ja gar nicht so die das mag vielleicht irgendwie eine deutsche
beschreibung haben mit schlechtem deutsch und ne irgendwie ein absender
der angeblich hier ist aber das ist ja alles so dropshipping also sprich die
typen auf wish die bestellen ja gar nicht wirklich also nein man bestellt ja
gar nicht wirklich bei den typen auf wish sondern man bestellt bei den typen
auf wish in irgendeinem china shop und die schicken das noch nicht mal also die
geben den auftrag nur weiter an den china shop und der schickt es dann durch also richtig
richtig hängen geblieben also wer also wer da bestellt der weiß da weiß ich auch
nicht weiter wish kannst du komplett kriegen bekommt man auf der china seite
eine ps5 das ist eine gute frage die ps5 ist bestimmt verboten in china in china
ist alles verboten aber eine ps4 kriegt man bei aliexpress immerhin was kosten
eigentlich die ps5 jetzt also bevor ich mir eine playstation 5 oder bevor ich mir eine xbox 5
ich habe weiß gar nicht wie die wie die aktuell überhaupt heißt xbox series x ist
glaube ich die aktuelle bevor ich mir eine neue playstation xbox bestellt dann
kaufe ich mir neuen rechner mit 30 90 rtx 5900 x und 64 g ram und und allem da
kaufe ich mir irgendwann noch also bevor ich das mache aus köln die an
available warum mal gucken ob so xbox gibt bestimmt deutschland mag keiner xbox aus anna
welbe xbox series x ist das die alte jetzt ist die xbox series x und die xbox
series s was ein unterschied hat sich nicht gemeldet wegen meinem tweet ach das
ist die das ist diese digital only hier unten ohne ohne laufwerk ja stimmt okay
gibt es die irgendwo noch also nicht dass ich jetzt eine kaufen will ich guck
noch mal
uer ready
put Mandником
juli
möglich ist
doch nur noch mal bei arzna um jetzt
Bundle gekauft mit, fragt mich nicht, FIFA 2008
oder so, oder 2010 oder irgendwas.
Ich hab es nie aufgemacht,
nie gespielt, nie
beachtet, aber ich hab
ein FIFA Bundle gekauft damals.
Einziges FIFA,
was ich mir gekauft hab,
war das Otto Xbox Series X
Excellent Chat. Ich bin ja
übrigens begeistert, dass Otto noch irgendwie,
die waren ja mal pleite vor ein paar Jahren,
das, oder wahrscheinlich gehören
die jetzt mittlerweile, fragt mich nicht, Ikea oder so,
keine Ahnung, aber das
Otto den, den,
die Kurve zum Onlinehandel noch gekriegt hat.
Otto, wie, wie, wie, warte mal, wie hießen
die Typen denn? Otto Quelle
Neckermann war das früher. Das waren so
die, die immer an die Omas Kataloge
verschickt haben und die haben sich dann da
Strumpfhosen bestellt oder was auch immer man
sich da so bestellt hat, keine Ahnung.
Ich hab nie Katalog bestellt
und die haben
komplett den Anschluss verloren.
Weißt du, gibt's die noch?
Nämlich Qualle.
Ja, okay, die gibt's auch noch.
Komisch,
komisch, komisch, noch ein Stonks-Logo.
Und die haben komplett den Anschluss verloren,
was Online, Online-Shops
angeht und dann waren sie irgendwann pleite.
Und außer anscheinend Otto, die haben noch
irgendwie die Kurve gekriegt, aber wahrscheinlich
gibt es nur noch den Namen und die
gehören gar nicht mehr, den, die es ursprünglich
da mal gehört hat oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Weiß nicht, wem die jetzt gehört.
Wobei, genau, die hatten ja auch mehr.
So, aber gut, hier gibt's noch eine neue Xbox. Exzellent.
Lieferung, aber eine Playstation haben die nicht mehr.
Garantiert nicht, weil in Deutschland sind Playstations
immer instant weg. Die Deutschen sind
übelste Playstation-Fanboys.
Ey, gibt's nicht.
Das war aber schon immer so. Deutschland war übel, war
richtig... Au.
Fuck.
Was ist denn los heute mit mir?
Au. Mich juckt's am Auge, ne?
Und ich drück so ein bisschen hier aufs Auge und juck mich.
Und es tut übelst weh.
Was ist denn los? Bin ich jetzt gerade am
Max broken oder kaputt?
RIP. F.
Bald ist vorbei.
Nee, gibt nix mehr.
Tja, so. Gehen wir mal kurz auf Amazon.
Ich will euch nämlich mal
was zeigen.
Ich hab nämlich mal wieder
was bestellt, was
wir im Stream ausprobieren können.
Ihr kennt mich, ihr kennt mich. Wenn ich
Steckdosenleisten sehe,
die man flashen kann mit Custom-Firmware,
ich kann mich nicht zurückhalten.
Ich hab mittlerweile,
glaub ich, acht Steckdosen. So viel brauch ich
im Leben nicht, Alter.
So.
Im Leben brauch ich die nicht, so.
Und ich hab mal wieder neue Steckdosenleisten bestellt,
die man angeblich mit Tasmota flashen kann.
Also ihr wisst ja, Steckdosenleisten,
Steckdosenleisten,
da, äh,
die müssen bei mir alle mit Custom-Firmware betrieben werden.
Und generell dieses Custom-Firmware-Flashen,
das ist gar nicht mal,
gar nicht mal so doof, ne?
Viele sagen ja immer, Max, warum flashst
du Custom-Firmware und das ist doch total
sinnlos. Ähm.
Wenn du einfach das Normale, was ist der Vorteil von
Custom-Firmware? Ich hab's euch ja letztens
schon gezeigt. Ähm.
Aber zum Beispiel sowas
kannst du nur mit Custom-Firmware,
Leute, ich stell euch mal vor, ich war übrigens letztens
wieder an der Sonne.
Kann man sich gar nicht richtig vorstellen, oder?
Ich mein, es war knapp.
Ich weiß, ich hab's, ich hab's
gerade so überlebt. So.
Ähm. Genau, guck mal.
Also so unsinnig ist das Ganze
gar nicht. Ne, ich hab hier,
ich zeig euch jetzt nicht das Video,
wahrscheinlich haben's die meisten schon gesehen,
wo ich's das letzte Mal gezeigt hab, aber
ich hab hier in meinem Bad,
habe ich hier so einen Heizlüfter,
wenn's kühl ist, kann man anmachen,
weil halt kalt und Heizung braucht.
So, und hier,
Achtung.
Ich spul mal ein bisschen vor. Ja, ja, ich erklär grad noch.
So, und guck mal. Hier hab ich
jetzt einen NFC-Tag.
Wenn ich jetzt mein iPhone nehme,
und an den NFC-Tag halte,
dann
triggert iPhone NFC-Tag
erkannt, das triggert
Shortcuts, und Shortcuts
sendet, ja, ja, ich, ich,
ich, äh,
spiegel mich öfters mal irgendwo.
Dann gibt's dann Max, Max
FPS liegt aus der Suppe, war mein persönliches
Lieblings-Reveal-Video.
Aller, allerbeste. So, und dann geht das
Ganze hier über Shortcuts, über
Home Assistant, und dann
über Home Assistant, pass mal auf, also
jetzt kann man an und aus machen, dann geht der Heizlüfter an und
aus, wenn man das da dran hält, und das Ganze
guckt jetzt, geht er an, und das Ganze geht
nur, das, das weiß ich jetzt eigentlich nicht,
weil ich diese Steckdose mit
Custom-Firmware geflasht hab.
Das iPhone X kann keinen NFC-Tag
legen, wirklich?
Also, ich hab, hab ich nicht auch ein iPhone X?
Ah, nee, ich hab nen iPhone X, doch.
Ich hab nen XS, glaub ich. XR?
XR?
Nee, ich weiß es gar nicht. Chat, ihr
wisst das immer besser, was ich hab.
Ich glaub, ich hab nen XR.
Zeig mal her.
Ja, genau, ich hab eins, was
keine 50 Kameras
draußen hat.
Oder? Oh, bei Chat, ihr erkennt das doch bestimmt.
Was ist das für nen iPhone hier?
Was ist das hier? Erkennt man das
irgendwie? Erkennt das der Apple-Profi, was das ist?
Ah.
Ich glaub,
das ist ein XR.
Ich glaub, das ist ein XR. Warum hat denn das
XR nen NFC-Tag
und ein anderes X nicht?
Egal, Apple.
Apple-Logik. So.
Zumindest, das Ganze funktioniert nur,
weil ich diese
Steckdose hier Custom-Firmware geflasht
hab. Das ist der einzige Grund, warum das funktioniert.
Also, man sieht,
Custom-Firmware flashen
bringt's. Ach ja, und der
eigentliche Vorteil ist,
man braucht keine
China-Cloud für. Das ist eigentlich der allergrößte
Vorteil. Man hat nen Web-Interface und sowas,
aber das ist halt der größte
Vorteil. Man braucht nicht die offizielle China-App, man braucht
generell keine China-Cloud und man kann's
einbinden, wie man will.
Hier übrigens, Leute, jetzt muss ich grad nochmal
eine Sache los, ich hab mich erfreut.
Es muss unbedingt mal irgendeine
Gambling-Glücksspiel-Seite
müsste so ne, so ne,
nen
Twitter
Twitter-Hashtag-Wetten
machen, annehmen. Also sprich,
dass man drauf wetten kann, was morgen für
Hashtags trenden.
Ich wär reich, wenn die das machen.
Ich kann mittlerweile
so quasi Twitter-Empörung
auf zwei bis
drei Tage im Voraus predikten.
Ich seh nen Clip,
ich seh irgendwas und ich weiß,
das wird für Empörung sorgen auf
Twitter. Und zu 90%
ist das auch so.
Das müsste echt einer mal so ne Wettseite
machen. Da wette ich jeden Tag auf
Twitter-Tags und werd reich. Twitter-Hashtags.
Neues Code-Projekt. Das Problem
ist, glaub ich, gar nicht mal so die Seite zu programmieren,
sondern das rechtlich
und insgesamt alles gut zu, gut zu machen.
Ne?
Ja, was ich auch wieder witzig fand, ne?
Ich hab heut... Ihr wisst ja, ich hab mein
Twitter hab ich auf Andorra stehen.
Sieht man jetzt hier nicht, aber ich hab mein Twitter
auf Andorra stehen, dass ich mir diesen
ganzen Müll hier, die ganzen
Müll-Tags in Deutschland nicht geben muss.
Und heut Morgen, ich mach ab und zu mal Twitter auf
so auf
anonymen und guck, was in Deutschland trendet,
seh ich so, aha, nur trendet wieder.
Und das ist ja immer, wenn der Typ trendet,
dann hat er irgendwas vom Stapel gelassen,
wo sich ganz Twitter wieder empört.
Und ich hab mir den
Clip angeguckt, ich will jetzt gar nicht zu sehr drauf rumreiten,
ja, wir müssen gleich noch ein paar Sachen
einkaufen, aber ich hab mir den
Clip angeguckt und als ich diesen
Clip gesehen hab, wusste ich,
Twitter wird eskalieren.
Die drehen wieder voll am Rad.
Also,
Hashtag draufgeguckt, was ist, Twitter ist
komplett am eskalieren, komplett
durch...
komplett durch, ja,
im Kopf.
Man könnte, man könnte jetzt eigentlich
sagen, ähm,
wenn er, wenn er das schafft mit so einer,
ja, was ist denn das, ich guck das
nicht, was ist das, so eine Art Satire-Sendung
oder sowas, keine Ahnung.
Also, wenn der das schafft, mit dieser Sendung
so viel Kontroverse auszulösen,
da kann er zumindest diesen Teil
seines Jobs gar nicht so schlecht machen,
weil es scheint ja zu funktionieren.
Ich guck mir das nicht an, ich hab diesen Clip gesehen,
manche Sachen waren halt belegbar
Schwachsinn, wie das dieses Buch in den USA erschienen ist,
aber mir war klar, die Leute
gehen total drauf ab.
Was ich ja nicht verstehe ist,
warum sind alle
aktuell so geil drauf,
sich über irgendwas aufzuregen.
Kann man nicht einfach
irgendwie sich mit dem, irgendwie damit
abfinden, dass
heute lacht man über irgendwas
und morgen lachen halt mal andere über einen.
So, solange sich das
in der Waage hält, ist doch alles okay.
Aber nee,
das geht nicht.
Da muss man ja erstmal hier, äh,
den Weltuntergang
ausrufen, wenn da was ist.
Ich hab auch das Gefühl, jetzt wo
Corona ist, den Leuten ist es noch langweiliger
und die können sich noch mehr aufregen
über so einen Kack.
Es ist eigentlich überhaupt nicht wert, sich da drüber aufzuregen.
Aber die gehen da ab, immer.
Oh meine Güte.
Also, die sind halt auch,
da setzt auch echt bei allen komplett
der Verstand aus, wenn es um irgendwie so ihre
Lieblingsthemen geht.
Äh, was? Wo bloß, du alter
IoT-Bastler, hast du Ahnung von guten Funk-
Standards, beziehungsweise Protokoll für sich?
Äh, ja, ja, ja, hab ich.
Da gibt's aber eigentlich nur eins.
Da gibt's eigentlich nur eins, was sinnvoll,
sinnvoll nutzbar ist, und das ist
LoRa. Äh, jetzt ist,
wobei, stimmt nicht, das stimmt nicht,
was ich gesagt hab, es gibt zwei, die sinnvoll
nutzbar sind.
Nee, LoRa brauchst du, kannst du selbst
machen, hab ich auch selbst gemacht. Also, wenn du
alter IoT-Bastler bist, dann ist das kein Problem.
Also, es gibt die Sache, einmal
bei LoRa zu machen, oder,
äh, mit ner SIM-Karte.
Also, das ist gar nicht mal so teuer.
Äh, Vodafone-Datentarif
für, äh, IoT. Das ist gar
nicht mal so teuer mit ner SIM-Karte.
Ich glaub, ich glaub 2 Euro
im Monat oder so. Äh.
What the fuck?
Können die denn nicht einfach mal ne Preisliste machen?
Ich hab letztens was gefunden.
Prepaid-Datentarife.
Moment, wo war das denn?
IoT-SIM-Tarif.
Wann das war das?
Telefonica, war das gar nicht Vodafone?
Ja, genau. Also, keine Ahnung.
So, hier, äh, IoT-Deutschland,
äh, 12 Monate, Anzahl
SIM-Karten 1, äh, Datenpakete
pro SIM, keine Ahnung, 5.
So. Ich mein,
1,39, das ist okay?
10 Euro für
10 Jahre. Was? 10 Euro
für 10 Jahre? Moment, wo?
Also, 10 Euro für
10 Jahre würd ich sofort kaufen.
Wo steht das mit 10 Euro für 10 Jahre?
Ah, okay.
Telekom, IoT, ach Moment, News.
Nee, das ist schon.
Das gibt's wahrscheinlich nicht mehr.
Was ist denn
1?
Ab sofort möglich.
1.
1 IoT-SIM.
Schau mal, IoT Easy Connect.
Easy as
Fuck Connect. Können wir auch gleich
mal gucken. Ja, also, ähm,
neben LoRa, zu LoRa sag ich gleich was,
weil ich hab schon was in LoRa gebaut,
sogar im Stream haben wir
das gemacht. Moment.
Äh, Twitter.
Ah, ich hab nämlich mal ein Bild gepostet
von dieser Kiste,
wie das bei mir ausschaut mit der, mit, ähm,
dem
LoRa Gateway.
So, also erstmal gucken,
was wollen die denn hier?
Es gibt 10 Euro
pro Unit, Specifications, okay.
Was ist da, was ist da drinne?
JavaCard?
Ernsthaft?
Ich hoffe mal,
das hat mit Java nix, nix zu tun,
will ich die nicht. Ja, genau,
Axi. Aber, wie gesagt,
das, ähm, das, äh,
das geht ja nicht um mich. Hat ja einer grad im Chat gefragt.
So, ähm,
wo steht denn jetzt,
was ist, was da drinne ist? Bin ich jetzt doof?
Wo steht's denn jetzt, was da,
was da dabei ist?
Over the Air Update über SMS.
Hardware Features?
Ja, was ist denn da jetzt dabei?
Ich, ich kapier's net.
Flatrate, SIM-Karte.
Hä?
Das, die Seiten sind so kompliziert,
das ist zu, zu,
bin ich zu low brain für.
Flatrate, aha, hier, hier.
10 Euro für 10 Jahre?
Ey, das ist
Poggers. Das ist ziemlich
nice.
Ich hab mir auch erst letztens nen, nen
Board gekauft mit SIM.
Ja, also, um nochmal
zu dieser Sache mit, äh,
einem Kilometer Funkstandards,
zu kommen. Also, es gibt meiner Meinung nach
zwei Varianten, die man machen kann.
Entweder über LoRa oder
über SIM. LoRa hat den Vorteil,
man kann deutlich low
powerige Boards,
also man bekommt wohl deutlich low
low power, mehr low power Boards
mit LoRa als mit SIM-Karte.
Mit SIM-Karte fällt mir da jetzt zumindest
von den üblichen Verdächtigen,
ESP28, ESP2866, äh,
82, 66,
nur eins ein und das ist nicht so extrem
low power, als dass es sich für Batterie eignet.
So, und, ähm,
mit LoRa
hab ich dieses
Ding
als Gateway,
mach ich mal das Image,
dieses Teil hab ich als
Gateway bei uns.
Da hab ich, da hab ich ein 3D,
3D-Case ausgedruckt
und hab das Ding unters Dach gestellt.
Das ist als Gateway
vollkommen ausreichend. Das kostet ja auch
nicht die Welt. Das kostet 16 Euro
auf Banggood, also diese 150
Euro Gateways ist total, total
übertrieben. Ähm,
genau.
Und dann brauchst du noch irgendeinen
Client halt.
Und da hab ich nen
ESP32 Firebeetle
mit, äh, nem LoRa-Modul
dran. Ja, aber wie gesagt, das ist
nicht sonderlich gut für
an der Batterie. Das ist für, für
ein Gateway gut. Das hat, Moment,
ist das überhaupt das richtige Board?
Also, genau, genau.
Ich hab da noch ein Display dran, richtig, richtig, genau.
Ich würd's dir zeigen,
ich würd's dir
zeigen, wenn ich wüsste, wo ich's hab.
Warte mal, ich mach dir mal ein Foto.
Warte mal. Ich glaub, ich weiß, wo's ist.
Ja, also,
hm, ehrlich gesagt,
davor ein Foto machen, weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob sich das jetzt wirklich
großartig lohnt, weil ich hab die Antenne
nicht dran, das sieht gar nicht so cool aus, wie's dann
halt aussieht, so.
Ähm, hab auch keinen Strom
dran und so. Ich mach dir trotzdem mal
kurz ein Foto.
So. Wobei,
Moment.
Moment, ich stream das einfach, ich hab doch die Kamera.
Ha, Moment, Leute.
Excellent. Wo, wo ist mein, wo ist mein
iPhone mit, mit der Kamera?
Pass mal auf, ich, jetzt, jetzt mal hier.
High, high, high interactive, big brain stream.
Ich muss das iPhone holen.
So, also, Fingerreveal,
genau. Also, ich mach jetzt mal den
Livestream an vom iPhone.
In der Hoffnung, ich schmeiß ihn wieder nicht
wieder die Hälfte runter, hier.
So, voll C.
Äh, wo hab ich denn
Livestream?
Wo ist es denn?
Äh, hier?
Kamera?
Zack. So, ich mach's mal an.
So, ähm.
Ja, ich kann's auch in OBS einbinden,
aber so ist's einfacher.
So, also.
Genau, jetzt kann ich dir das zeigen,
und zwar, ich hab jetzt
leider keine Antenne dran, aber du kannst das wahrscheinlich
ungefähr, ungefähr vorstellen,
nicht. Durch das Case hab ich selbst
ausgedruckt. Da drinnen ist
quasi das Board, was ich dir eben gezeigt
hab. Also, sprich,
äh, ne, die Go-Board.
Und,
hier sind die Kürse.
Aufmachen kann ich's jetzt nicht, weil ich hab
in einfacher
Weise zuge...
zugeschraubt.
Aber das Teil,
das stellst du dir einfach unter das Dach,
und dann kannst du deine ganzen
LoRa, deine ganzen LoRa
Dinger, kannst du
damit ansprechen.
Naja gut, äh, wenn du Gateway
meinst, du meinst dieses,
du meinst dieses, ähm,
Things Network.
Das kannst du damit auch machen,
aber hab ich nicht.
Ich mein, wozu auch?
Ich beweg mich innerhalb von einem Kilometer,
ich brauch keine, kein Thing, äh, äh,
wie heißt das?
The Things Network, oder so?
Jaja, End-to-End
geht. Ich hab das schon ausprobiert.
Ich hab auf, ich hab auf dem Friedhof
einen, äh,
Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor
versucht zu installieren und zu kommunizieren
und das war so ungefähr 1,2
Kilometer weg. Und das ging.
Allerdings nur auf langsam, auf
langsamsten Modus. So, und ich hab noch ein
Display drangemacht, da sieht man glaub ich dann die
Empfangsstärke oder sowas. Ich mach mal kurz,
ich mach mal kurz Strom rein, mal gucken was dann
auf dem Display kommt. Ich hatte das ewig nicht mehr an.
Jaja, das, ey, LoRa
ist übelst nice, das kriegst du bis zu
10 Kilometer oder noch weiter
bei, äh, Sichtlinie wohlgemerkt.
Und umso höher man ist, umso besser.
Auch mal kurz irgendein USB-Kabel zum
anmachen. Leuchtet.
Angehen tut's net.
Ja gut, ähm,
keine Ahnung, was ich da gebaut hab,
warum das Display nicht angeht. Kein Schimmer, ich
hatt's jetzt schon ne Weile nicht mehr in Betrieb.
Ich mach wieder ab. Zack.
Äh, und ich
schließ mal mein iPhone kurz ans Ladegerät
an, falls man das nochmal braucht.
Exzellent. So, also.
Wisste?
Da sagt mal einer, ich würd nicht auf den Chat eingehen
oder sowas. Genau. Aber das sind auch
Themen, die mich interessiert. Ich geb zu, manchmal
geh ich nicht auf den Chat an, wenn's so Sachen sind, wo ich
keinen Bock hab, drüber zu reden. Aber, ähm,
ansonsten muss man sagen, haben wir hier schon wirklich ziemlich
viel Chat-Interaktion und auch
wirklich viel hilfsbereite Leute im
Chat. Ich hab's das letzte Mal gesagt.
Also, ich bin der Meinung, ich hab den
besten Chat. Und jetzt ohne
zu schleimen, es ist unglaublich selten,
dass man auf Twitch das Ganze sieht,
dass die Leute im Chat nicht untereinander
rum mimen und untereinander rumtrollen.
Ich mein, das machen wir natürlich auch, ja.
So ist das nicht. Das gehört auf Twitch dabei.
Aber,
hier helfen sich die Leute wirklich auch
im Chat. Es ist, äh,
echt nice, ja.
Was war das für Doorcam im Bild?
Äh, was?
Was meinst du?
Hast du noch nen Namen für das Image? Ich hab das
selbst programmiert. Hab ich nicht.
Nein. Ich hab, äh,
ich, ich, ich kann ja auch noch nicht mal mehr sagen,
ehrlich gesagt, was ich für ne Library
verwendet hab.
Ja, danke für den Prime-Sub übrigens.
Excellent. Ja, genau, also
IoT-SIM, also ich muss sagen, das find ich echt
gut. 10 Euro für 10 Jahre
flat, da kann man wirklich was
machen. Das ist zum Beispiel sowas,
wenn man einen Tracker im Auto
haben will, der nur GPS trackt,
ab und zu mal, da
kommt man mit 500 MB wahrscheinlich
halbwegs hin.
Denk ich mal.
X oder
exquisite Subscription,
Dankeschön. Im Bild als
LOL, also Dom-PC, ich hab echt keine Ahnung,
was du meinst. Was haben die denn
für ne Taktung?
Ähm, die, die,
die Dinger. Keine Ahnung,
240 MHz, Dual-Core
240 MHz oder so.
So, ähm,
ja, also wenn das natürlich nur 500
MB für
10 Jahre sind, da muss man
ganz schön sparsam sein.
Ach,
die Taktung meinst du ja, da müsste man tatsächlich
mal gucken. Aber, sag
man mal so, mal angenommen, man möchte
wirklich so ne Art GPS-Tracker
machen, dann
brauchste, ich würd mal sagen,
so, pff, was braucht
man denn da? So nen
Request, so nen
Kilo-Byte pro Request oder so?
Äh,
äh, Moni, kann ich nicht zu, kann ich wirklich nicht
viel zu sagen. Äh,
ich hab bei mir nen Keystone-Panel,
aber das, ja, ich hab da
keinen großen Effekt. Also wenn man ungefähr nen Kilo-Byte
pro Request annimmt,
so, das
kommt ja ungefähr hin. Was ist, was ist
GPS-Koordinaten großartig?
Das sind Koordinaten, Längengrad, Breitengrad,
Höhe vielleicht noch. Also da kommt's mit nem Kilo-Byte
pro Request bestimmt gut hin.
Da kommt noch ein bisschen HTTP oder so vielleicht dabei,
aber da kommt man wahrscheinlich mit nem Kilo-Byte pro Request
ganz gut hin. So, Kilo-Byte,
dann sagen wir mal, du machst, du machst am Tag
irgendwie, macht man dann
am Tag so 10, 10, ähm,
ja gut, nee, eigentlich musst du
das machen, je nachdem. Kann ich sagen, 20,
20, 20 Dinge am
Tag machst du, also sprichst du 20
Kilo-Byte, 20 Kilo-Byte
am Tag, 20 Kilo-Byte,
so, und dann brauchst du im Jahr
365, äh, meinst du,
20 mal, so,
so, dann brauchst du 7
Kilo-Byte im Jahr,
das sind 7,6
mal 3 MB,
da kommst du doch,
da kommst du doch locker mit hin.
Meinst du nicht, ein Kilo-Byte-Request
reicht? Doch, guck mal,
Kilo-Byte ist ganz schön viel.
Ich meine, man muss es ja nicht über HTTP machen,
über HTTP kommt das ganze Header-Gedöns und so
noch dabei. Ja, doch, das könnte,
könnte hinkommen. Also, das ist ein echt
interessantes Angebot, das kannte ich noch nicht,
das ist wirklich, das ist echt nice.
Also, für solche Anwendungsgebiete,
wie ich eben grad beschrieben hab, ist das nix.
Also, äh, ultra laufend,
Power und Sim ist
schwierig, aber wofür das zum Beispiel
gut ist, beispielsweise um Autos
zu tracken oder sowas.
Oder, oder irgendwas,
wo halt ein Stromanschluss ist.
Glaub ich ganz gut. So, aber
das ist wirklich nice, das gefällt mir. So,
kann das jeder kaufen oder muss man da irgendwie
500 Stück abnehmen oder sowas?
Ey, ey, Moni, ich muss dir ehrlich sagen, ich weiß
gar nicht, was LSA Plus ist.
Ist das Glasfaser-Zeug?
KRONE LSA Plus.
Weiß nicht, was das ist.
Höh!
Ihh, was ist denn das?
Wie gesagt, ich weiß gar nicht, was das ist.
Jaja, also kann das jeder kaufen,
also mal angenommen, ich will das jetzt, mal angenommen, ich will das jetzt kaufen.
China Plus, excellent.
Guck mal, man kann sogar rebooken.
So, wie?
Okay, buy, buy, okay.
Ach, das ist
das schon.
One, ten years, 500 MB.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich nice.
Ne, kenn ich nicht.
Sbarro.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Das gefällt mir, das hat was.
So, mal angenommen, man bestellt jetzt da 10,
zahlt mal 100 Euro.
Das ist doch, eigentlich ist
das nice. Ich find das richtig gut.
Ich bin jetzt ernsthaft am überlegen, ob ich
nicht irgendwelche Dinger mit
SIM-Karte bastle.
Einfach, weil's geht.
Ich hab mir ja letztens diesen SIM-Karten,
dieses SIM-Karten-Board bestellt.
Ähm, hier, wartet mal, das da.
TT-Go-SIM.
Ne, T-Call
hieß das, glaub ich.
TT-Go-T-Anruf.
Das Teil hab ich mir
letztens bestellt.
Und das hat halt einen SIM-Karten-Slot
dabei. Aber ich hab mir
nur eins bestellt, weil ich wollt's mal ausprobieren.
Das heißt, ich hab sogar ein Board mit
SIM-Karte da. Also ich bin
da jetzt wirklich, ich bin kurz
davor, mir da mal eine zu
bestellen. Und ihr kennt mich, Leute. Ihr wisst, ich bestell
nie eine, ich bestell immer mindestens drei.
Nein.
Brauch ich nicht.
Ich find, das ist cool. Das hat was.
Moment, warum kostet das Shipping?
Ih.
Ah, das G-Baid.
Da kommt noch Mehrwertsteuer
drauf. Hat das GPS?
Moment, hat
das hier GPS? Ey,
by the way, der, der eben gefragt hat, nee, ich glaub,
das hat das an GPS.
Äh, by the way, der, der eben gefragt hat,
wegen diesem
LoRa-Board, das
hat GPS drauf. Das ist ein richtig
guter, nennen wir's mal richtig guter
Gateway oder halt, halt
Endpunkt
für sowas. Das ist echt praktisch.
Du hast GPS drin und LoRa drin.
Das heißt, du kannst Zeit abrufen.
Ich wollt' mir damit schon mal einen
NTP-Server bauen. So einfach, weil's geht mit
mit GPS-Uhr, aber totaler Schwachsinn, wozu.
Genau, und das Ding hier hat einen
Anschluss für Batterie.
SIM-Karte und halt eine Antenne,
die man draußen, draußen dranpappen
kann. Die Sache ist die, es ist nicht
extrem low power.
Es ist, äh, wobei, ist ja mal
so, wir können das mit GPS machen.
GPS, so ein GPS-Modul
kostet ja nicht so viel. Das kostet wahrscheinlich
6 Euro oder sowas.
Hier.
GPS, GPS-Modul.
Ja.
Na, in Rust, äh,
du kannst theoretisch in Rust
programmieren, aber das ist doch sehr Alpha.
Du musst höchstwahrscheinlich, äh, mit C++
ran. Dafür
kannst du Arduino benutzen.
So. Das ist powered
bei Telekom, wirklich. Ja, ist mir doch
wurscht, von wem die powered sind.
Übrigens, Leute, ich hab
das jetzt, ich hab das jetzt gemacht. Wir haben ja letztens im
Stream, haben wir doch hier dieses Angebot von
1&1 gesehen. Ich weiß, 1&1
und...
Ja, man kann sich da lang drüber lustig machen.
Und, ähm,
ich hab mir jetzt zum Testen
meinen Server gekauft bei 1&1.
Und zwar...
Nein, nein, kein
Wordpress.
Wo ist er denn?
In 1 Euro. 1, 1, 1 Euro.
Server hab ich mir gekauft.
Wo ist er denn?
Bin ich jetzt blöd?
VPS-Hosting. See Packages.
2?
What? Nein, nein, nein.
S. 2 im Monat?
Wollt ihr mich verarschen? Nein, nein, das hat 1 gekauft.
VPS-Hosting. Genau.
Äh, wo ist es denn?
Hier, Server.
VPS.
Hier, den hab ich mir gekauft.
Äh,
und da ist mir was aufgefallen beim Einrichten.
Und zwar, wenn man sich das, wenn man sich
das kaufen will, die, die,
die sind nicht so, nicht so
wirklich zeitgemäß, was
Cloud und Server angeht.
Das war dein Mitbewohner A, verstehe.
Excellent.
So, und wenn man das kaufen will,
dann wird einem nämlich irgendwann auffallen,
dass die einen gleich für
12 Monate in Beschlag
nehmen wollen. Also, die haben das so
mit Cloud und On Demand noch nicht so ganz kapiert.
Bei anderen Anbietern kannst du
nämlich Server erstellen und gleich wieder ausmachen. Aber
ja, ich verstehe, warum die das
machen. 1 Euro ist wirklich
ziemlich günstig. Wenn du dir mal anguckst,
bei Hetzner kostet, glaube ich,
den ganzen Monat laufen zu lassen, Sibaro,
du weißt das besser, du hast letztens die Sachen gekauft
bei Hetzner. Wahrscheinlich kostet es bei Hetzner
irgendwie 3,50 oder so. Und wenn man das den ganzen Monat
laufen lässt. Oder 2,80.
Aber, also,
ich finde es okay.
Es ist ein bisschen merkwürdig, ja, mit diesen 12 Monaten.
So, und da dachte ich mir noch, okay,
weißt du was,
gehst du mal auf einen Monat runter.
Ich meine, willst du den Server doch eigentlich einfach
nur mal testen. Und wenn man auf einen Monat
runter geht, guck mal,
einmalige Einrichtungsgebühr 10 Euro.
Ja, also das ist
eindeutig künstliches
teuer machen, dass man 12 Monate nimmt.
Was anderes ist das nicht. Weil ich meine, du hast
die Auswahl, 12 Monate
für 12 Euro.
Oder,
ähm,
ein Monat für 11 Euro.
Warum sollte man
das machen?
Top Deal, ja. Aber ganz im
Ernst, 12 Monate
1 Euro geht in Ordnung.
So. Ansonsten, wie gesagt,
benutze ich ja mittlerweile, ich habe früher immer
ganz viel DigitalOcean verwendet.
Aber, wenn man das mal vergleicht,
äh, Pricings,
also, wie gesagt, früher habe ich
Pricing,
früher habe ich immer relativ viel DigitalOcean
verwendet für so On-Demand-Server,
was man mal braucht. Zum Beispiel, wenn
ich mal OpenStreetView,
nicht OpenStreetView, äh, Open,
Moment, wie heißen sie, Open,
blöd, OpenStreetMaps,
nee, OpenStreet,
OpenStreetMaps, genau. Wenn ich da mal
Karten konvertieren muss, da habe ich mir
manchmal hier bei, ähm,
bei DigitalOcean habe ich mir manchmal so eine fette
Liste gemietet, hier mit irgendwie 64G,
32 CPU und sowas, dass die Sachen schnell
processed waren. Dass der Kram im Monat
640 Euro kostet, ist egal,
weil ich bin nach 2-3 Stunden
durch und bezahle dann 2,50 Euro oder so.
Ja, das ist hier natürlich nicht so,
aber mittlerweile
bin ich hier hängen geblieben und das meiste,
was ich mir mache, hole ich mir echt bei Hetzner.
Hetzner hat mehr oder
weniger ähnliche Pakete
wie DigitalOcean, ist
hier in Deutschland, gut, DigitalOcean hat auch
eine gute Anwendung, da muss man, kann man nichts sagen,
aber es kostet nur die Hälfte von DigitalOcean.
So,
ähm, und hier kannst du
einen Server laufen lassen für 2,89
den Monat, ich meine, das ist jetzt nicht der
Wahnsinn, ne, eine virtuelle CPU,
2 GB RAM, aber
dafür 20 TB Traffic, damit kann man schon
ein bisschen was abfackeln.
Locations, Nürnberg,
Falken, Horst
oder so und, und, Finnland.
Aber das ist halt nochmal eine Ecke billiger.
So, und worauf ich raus will ist, es ist
irgendwo okay, dass die 12 Euro wollen.
Genau, das
Archiv und die Webseite läuft, läuft
auch. Ja, Sibaro, kein Problem, ich bin
ja froh, dass du dieses Archiv so gewissenhaft
machst, jetzt schon so lang.
Genau, aber das
es lohnt sich eigentlich, ist schon
okay, ja. Und bis jetzt bin ich
damit ehrlich gesagt auch ganz zufrieden gewesen.
NetCap habe ich noch nie
ausprobiert. Server.
Was haben die denn da?
Es ist im Prinzip ähnlich.
Ist im Prinzip ähnlich.
Das nimmt sich jetzt nicht viel.
Ist ziemlich ähnlich. Eine CPU,
2 GB RAM, ein bisschen
mehr Snapshot, ein bisschen mehr Traffic,
aber ganz ehrlich, 20 TB Traffic.
Wir haben es doch ausprobiert. Ich habe doch
bei Hetzner mal einen Speedtest-Server installiert für euch.
Und wir haben das am Ende, haben wir es
irgendwie geschafft, keine Ahnung,
400 MB oder so Traffic
zu machen. Und da hat der ganze Chat
rumgespammt.
Tja, aber um jetzt nochmal schnell
die Sache hier abzuschließen, ich bin da komplett sidetracked
worden mittlerweile. Das finde ich richtig
gut. Das werde ich ausprobieren.
Ich werde mir das mal bookmarken.
Da werde ich mir drei Stück von bestellen.
Und, äh,
ja, ne, das machen wir jetzt nicht hier
im Stream. Da werde ich mir drei Stück
von bestellen und mal gucken, wie weit man mit
500 MB und einer 10 Jahre Sim-Karte
kommt. Weil das ist ja mal ein Wort.
10 Jahre, 500 MB. Easy.
Und wenn man, wenn man wirklich davon
ausgeht, dass man 1 KB
pro Request braucht, ungefähr über den
Daumen gepeilt, um ein bisschen GPS
Daten zu verschicken, dann muss man halt mal
zur Abwechslung ein bisschen effizient
Progress machen.
Ist in Ordnung, ja. Ist schon
okay. Und man kann das ja dann
richtig big brain machen, wisst ihr?
Man kann das ja sogar so machen,
man kann, wenn man, mal angenommen, man legt
das ins Auto und
möchte Auto-GPS,
sein Auto-GPS tracken
oder was auch immer. Oder das Auto vom
Opa-GPS tracken, dass er sich nicht verfährt
oder so. So, und, ähm,
da könnte man sogar, weil
das schließt man ja eh an diesen 12 Volt
auf USB,
würde ich dann im Auto machen und das Ding irgendwo
in die Ecke pappen mit Heißkleber oder so.
Und, ähm, da kann man ja die Sache
richtig big brain machen. Man nimmt,
man nimmt die SIM-Karte
und dann macht man sich noch so einen Acceleration-Sensor
dran. Und dann kann man sogar
quasi mitbekommen, wann das Auto
beschleunigt und wann
das Auto bremst.
Und wenn das Auto quasi,
sagen wir, für
10 Minuten
sich nicht mehr bewegt hat,
dann kann man
einen GPS-Update schicken oder so.
Das wäre eigentlich eine richtig
coole Sache. Was, äh,
was, was bringt eigentlich dieses Narrowband-IoT?
Habe ich noch nie ausprobiert, keine Ahnung.
Sagt mir auch
nix.
So, ja, also,
jetzt sind wir ja erst mal übelst
sidetracked worden. Aber kommen wir
mal zurück zu China und
Einkaufen und AliExpress.
Ich muss mal meine Liste aufmachen. Ja,
AliExpress ist gut.
Die spammen einen immer so übertrieben voll.
Genau, ähm,
genau, das ist, genau, das ist das eine, was ich euch zeigen
wollte, habe ich euch jetzt gezeigt. Werden wir mal wieder
versuchen, ähm,
hm...
Ja, eine Batterie hast du schon
recht. Eine Batterie sollte man vielleicht schon rein
machen, dass das Dinge mal so ein paar
Stunden überbrücken kann.
Wobei das auch nicht schlimm ist. Wozu, wozu?
Es reicht ja,
wenn es ab und zu mal
angeht. Da muss man sich mal Gedanken
machen. Ist
da Traffic mit oder ohne TCP plus
IP? Äh, das ist alles
mit. Das ist ganz normal alles, was
du drüber machst. Also sprich, wenn du da
jetzt HTTPS, äh,
drüber machst und die Pakete
größer sind und
zig, dreißig Milliarden Header dranhängst,
das geht alles da rein. Aber ich gehe trotzdem
davon aus, dass man mit einem Kilobyte
locker hinkommt pro, pro GPS
Koordinatenupdate.
Ach so, darüber kann man das auch erkennen. Ja.
Ja, stimmt. Genau, also,
ähm, das probieren wir demnächst mal im
Stream aus, ob man das Ding flashen kann.
Weil ihr wisst ja, ich kann nicht widerstehen, wenn es Steckdosenleisten
zum Flashen gibt.
Ähm, da wollte ich euch noch was anderes
zeigen. Und zwar, ich hab, jetzt muss ich mal kurz
hochscrollen. Übrigens,
Avira geht mir mega auf den
Sack gerade. Ich hab ja auf dem alten
Rechner, über den ich euch hier die Vorschau hab, wo ich,
wo ich den Chat seh und sowas,
hab ich ja immer noch Avira drauf. Fragt mich nicht, in welcher
geistigen Umnachtung ich mich befunden hab, dass
ich da Avira draufgemacht hab. Das ist da schon
seit vier Jahren oder so drauf. Ich hab's einfach nicht runtergeschmissen.
Diese...
die Kollegen hier.
Ja.
Und das poppt
permanent auf und
erzählt mir, dass es irgendwelche unsicheren
Settings gefunden hat. Da klickst du
drauf und es ist kein Virus oder so.
Wie soll da auch draufkommen auf den Rechner? Da ist ja nichts
außer Vorschau. Ähm, und da sagt
er mir, dass ich irgendwelche unsicheren System Settings
hab oder so. Das soll einfach mal die Klappe halten, wenn ich
auf den Sack geh. Gibt es einen Black
Friday Shopping Stream?
Wann ist denn das denn? Nächste Woche?
...
27. November.
Ja. Exzellent.
Soll ich euch
nochmal auch was anderes sagen,
was auch extrem exzellent ist?
Ich muss
jetzt genau noch Dienstag
arbeiten,
Mittwoch arbeiten
und dann hab ich eine Woche,
zwei Wochen, drei Wochen,
vier Wochen,
fünf Wochen, sechs Wochen,
sieben Wochen, acht...
Ne, die hab ich doppelt gezählt. Sieben
Wochen Urlaub. Oh, Moment.
What the...
Microsoft, warum geht
der Pfeil nach oben, nach unten?
Was... Alter, da waren
die Usability-Experten von Microsoft wieder am Start, ey.
Also,
nochmal.
Ne, im Monat nach oben
würde ich sagen, da kommt November, wenn ich
nach oben gehe, weil es geht ja nach oben, also
hoch. Die meinen
hier nach hoch scrollen. Okay, das ist nicht so schön gemacht.
Ganz ehrlich, über solche Windows-Sachen
mach ich mir schon keinen Gedanken mehr.
Ähm, so, also
nochmal. Also, eine Woche,
zwei Wochen, drei Wochen,
vier Wochen, fünf Wochen,
sechs Wochen, sieben Wochen.
Excellent.
Sieben Wochen Urlaub, so muss das sein.
Länger als Sommerferien, ja.
Sehr nice.
Ihm soll ich folgen auf Twitter.
Dem UnderSerial, Alpha4Games
und dem CommanderKrieger. Ah ja.
Excellent. So, ähm,
genau, und ich wollte euch noch was anderes
zeigen, weil das hab ich mir schon gekauft und das müssen wir
jetzt nicht kaufen. Ich muss jetzt nicht im Stream
faken, dass ich was kaufe, was ich
schon gekauft hab. Und zwar,
ich hab angefangen mit, ich hab's
glaub ich in einem der letzten Streams schon erzählt,
mit ein bisschen RGB-Beleuchtung.
Bei mir daheim. Also, ihr wisst ja,
dass ich heimautomatisierungsmäßig schon ganz
fett mit dabei bin, also da
baue ich ja seit Jahren schon dran rum.
Ähm, aber ich hab bisher mich
nie großartig für
Beleuchtung interessiert. By the way, ich zeige euch mal kurz
was. Beleuchtung. Moment.
Okay. Ich hoffe, dass man das sieht.
So.
Ich mach mal, ich kann's euch jetzt nicht direkt
zeigen, weil dann, dann, dann
dann leake ich mich selbst, ja.
Aber ich kann mal das Licht ausmachen
vom Tablet, äh, vom Handy.
Und jetzt,
und jetzt,
äh,
und jetzt, ich hab nämlich extra
mal
da was vorbereitet.
Excellent.
Heimautomatisierungs-Dashboard.
Ups.
No. Ähm,
hier, Arbeitszimmer.
Jetzt passt mal auf.
Äh, ich muss mal kurz den hier aufmachen, dass man's
irgendwie sieht.
Diesen LIFX, äh,
Lampen. So, ich kann jetzt hier sagen,
Arbeitszimmer sind wir. Ich muss das mal, glaub ich, ein bisschen
blitten.
Arbeitszimmer.
Also, das erste, was man machen kann, ist,
man kann heller machen.
Ich glaub, es ist, ihr habt's gesehen, es ist heller, ne?
Heller, dunkler. Also, es ist dimmbar.
Das ist jetzt ja nun wirklich kein, kein großartiges Ding.
Das können ja viele. So, jetzt ist quasi
mehr oder weniger fast aus.
Jetzt wieder volle Pulle. So, aber
was richtig cool ist an den Dinger,
ähm, erstens die Home Assistant-Integration
ist richtig nice.
Und, jetzt passt mal auf,
ähm,
man kann die Farbtemperatur,
man kann einstellen, welche Temperatur weiß ist.
Also, ich kann zum Beispiel sagen, okay, ich will's
relativ heiß, also blau.
Ähm, dann ist es eher so.
Das Licht. Wir müssen warten,
bis die Kamera sich angepasst hat.
So, und dann kann ich sagen, okay, ich will's jetzt eher kühl
haben. Äh,
äh, ne, die Temperatur
auch excellent, dann ist es eher rot.
Ne, warte mal.
Blau ist kalt? Ne,
blau ist heiß.
Blau ist kalt? Ernsthaft?
Aber Temperatur ist
blau heiß und rot kalt.
Warum heißt das dann Temperatur?
Ja, Chat, guck mal.
Temperatur. Wo ist die,
wo ist die Flamme heiß?
Am blauen oder am, am roten?
Dort, wo's blau ist.
Also, wenn ihr mal euch so nen Bunsenbrenner anguckt.
Dort, wo's blau ist,
ist der am heißesten. Nicht?
Doch, oder? Nicht so?
So, und,
und noch was?
Und noch was?
Blaues Licht ist ja auch,
hat ja auch mehr Energie als
rotes Licht, also zumindest hat rotes Licht größere Wellenlänge
als blaues. Okay, dann ist
es in dem Fall genau umgedreht. Zumindest,
man kann, man kann die, die Weißtemperatur
quasi so einstellen. So,
zumindest ist auch vollkommen egal, ob das stimmt,
was ich jetzt erzählt hab, aber
wie auch immer man das nennt.
Schau mal deinen Wasserhahn
an. Was hat mein Wasserhahn
mit meiner Licht
Temperatur zu tun?
Das muss ich jetzt nicht verstehen, oder?
Da ist blau auch immer kalt.
Ach, so meinen die das mit
heiß oder blau.
Ah.
Ja, aber, Leute, ihr müsst zugeben,
dass das meines auch
eine gewisse Logik hatte.
Die stimmt zwar nicht, die ist genau falsch rum,
aber das war nicht einfach random.
So, also,
um es
jetzt abzuschließen, also,
ne, wie gesagt, ich kann das jetzt
kälter machen, ich kann das, ich kann
das, ähm, ich kann das wärmer
machen. Ich hab's meistens,
so auf, äh, hier so auf 30, 30.
Die Kamera spackt jetzt ein bisschen rum bei.
Und man kann, wenn man
ganz hart drauf ist, kann man auch noch
hier RGB-Puffbeleuchtung machen.
Alter, sieht das kacke aus
jetzt hier, ey. Oder, oder
Sonnenlicht oder so.
Magenta!
Ist ja abartig, ey.
Zumindest was gut ist, worauf ich
raus will bei den, bei den Lampen,
ja, bei diesen Lampen.
Bevor ich da jetzt, wie gesagt, ich bekomme
kein Geld dafür,
ich wollte es euch aber halt mal zeigen.
Also, worauf
ich da raus will ist, was ihr
jetzt ja auch dran seht, ähm,
ich stell das mal kurz wieder ein bisschen zurück.
Das machen wir und
dann machen wir, so hatte ich's glaube ich
so irgendwie in dem Dreh, genau.
Ich lass mal auf, vielleicht,
vielleicht will ich da gleich nochmal was zeigen.
So, zumindest, ähm,
sind das diese Lampen hier.
Und die sind meiner Meinung nach eigentlich
viel zu teuer.
Um,
irgendwie
massenhaft gekauft zu werden.
Aber, ich muss sagen, ich find die Lampen wirklich nicht schlecht.
Weil, und das ist das,
was ihr jetzt auch gesehen habt, diese Dinger
haben ziemlich gute
Leuchtkraft, auch
bei eingestellten Farben. Weil du hast
viele dieser ganzen, ähm, RGB
Lampen, übrigens für diesen Preis würd ich nicht
kaufen, äh, also irgendwie 45 Euro
oder so würd ich da höchstens für ausgeben.
Müsst ihr mal woanders, also gibt's auf jeden Fall.
Ich hab, genau, ich hab auch so in dem Dreh hier
bezahlt. Ähm,
ist eigentlich viel zu teuer für
eine Lampe, aber viele dieser RGB
Lichter, oder RGB Lampen, die man so
kaufen kann,
die haben das
Problem, dass sie,
wenn man Farben einstellt, es übelst
dunkel ist. Also sprich, ich
stell das dann auf, auf, äh, keine Ahnung,
grün und es ist halt total furzl,
furzmäßig, äh,
funselig, ja. Und das
ist bei denen wirklich ganz gut. So, und,
ähm, wie gesagt,
für 45 Euro, 45 Euro
ist, ist echt ein stattlicher Preis
für eine Lampe wohlgemerkt, ja.
Also da ist jetzt gar keine Frage, dass das jetzt nix
ist, wo ich
das ganze Haus mit ausstatten würde. Die haben
auch ein bisschen günstigere. Also das hier ist die
fette Lampe, die sie haben, und dann haben sie noch Plus.
Die gibt's übrigens auch günstiger.
Man muss ja immer mal gucken, also diese Preise hier bei Amazon
sind total, total hängengeblieben gerade.
Also der Unterschied zwischen der und der ist,
ich zeig's euch mal beim Hersteller.
Wie gesagt, ich muss es nicht mal als
Werbung kennzeichnen.
Ähm,
ich, äh, krieg kein Geld für.
Genau. Aber was,
was ganz cool ist, die haben nämlich
neben diesen normalen
Lampen noch, wo ist es denn?
Genau.
Äh, genau. Es gibt die A19
oder A90 in Deutschland.
Die hat, äh, 1100 Lumen.
Steht, weiß nicht, ob das hier, ah, da steht
da. Und die haben noch
eine, ähm,
A19 Plus.
Und das ist wirklich ganz praktisch.
Die kann nämlich auch noch, ähm,
Infrarot-Licht.
Also sprich, wenn man
eine Kamera hat,
die
mit, mit Nachtsicht,
mit, mit Nachtsichtfunktion,
die aber selbst keine ordentliche
Infrarot-LEDs hat. Und meine Kameras
sind halt nicht so die übelst, äh,
High-Budget-Dinger.
Ich hab ja, ich hab ja davon welche.
Hab ich mir auch mal bei
Amazon.com gekauft im, im Bundle.
Als es die günstig
gab. Viel, viel, viel zu teuer.
Ich hab da 20 Euro oder so für bezahlt. Da
fuck. Warum ist das so teuer, Alter?
20 Euro das Stück hab ich
dafür bezahlt. Irgendwie in dem Dreh.
20, 22, 23 Euro.
Ähm, und die haben halt nicht so die
wahnsinnsgeile Infrarot-LED.
Sondern was ich jetzt gemacht hab ist,
ich hab unten im Flur
das Teil, das macht ganz normal RGB
Beleuchtung im Flur, aber nachts
ab 22 Uhr
schaltet das die Kamera, also schaltet, äh,
der Home Assistant schaltet
die Kamera in Nachtsicht,
macht den Infrarot-Filter aus
und macht die RGB-Lampe
aus und macht die, ähm,
Infrarot-Ansicht an.
Das heißt, ich kann jetzt unten den kompletten
Flur bei Nacht
sehen und kann der Katze beim
Rumstelzen zugucken.
Hast du die auch geflasht? Nee, hab ich nicht geflasht.
Aber die ist im IoT
WLAN, da, da passiert nix.
Man kann übrigens
auch sinnlose Sachen mit der Lampe machen, wie
Loops und pulsieren und
sonst was, aber das mach ich nicht.
Ja, genau. Und das Ding ist wirklich nice.
Ich hab jetzt mittlerweile
vier Stück, ähm,
so ne, so ne
A90 hab ich, dann hab ich noch
ne kleine
drüben
wieder. Dann noch eine,
die nur Helligkeit und, äh,
Weißton kann.
Also das ist smart,
smart, ähm, RGB
Blechung. Die find ich wirklich gut gemacht.
Das wollt ich jetzt eins bloß mal sagen.
Ob der Preis jetzt irgendwie
gerechtfertigt ist, 20 Euro für so ne,
für so ne einfache Lampe, muss man sich,
muss man sich überlegen.
Oder, oder 27, ist ganz schön
teuer. Da, also für den Preis von
einer normalen, hier 55 Euro,
kriegt man fünf, kriegt man vielleicht
fünf, äh, China RGB Lampen.
So, ich muss mal kurz Chat durchgucken,
dass ich nix übersehen hab.
Das menschliche Auge nimmt Farben unterschiedlich
intensiv wahr. Ja, und vor allem sieht das menschliche
Auge plus 12 FPS, das wissen wir ja alle.
Oh ja, bloß nicht.
Diese, ey, diese Strike-Geschichte
ist, läuft grad voll
aufm Ruder auf Twitch.
So, hab ich irgendwas übersehen?
Chat?
Rotlichtlampe gleich Wärmelampe.
Moment, aber, nee, nee, dass
die Rotlichtlampe warm macht,
ist doch nur, weil die
Rotlicht, äh, ne niedrige, ne längere
Wellenlänge hat und einfach in die Haut eindringen kann.
Oder Chat?
Wo sind hier die Physikleute?
So, ähm,
gibt's hier irgendwelche Sachen, die ich übersehen hab im Chat?
Äh, nutzt du Text, äh, nutzt
du Speech to Text?
Also sowas wie
Deep Speech oder Mycroft? Nö.
Ich, äh,
Leute, die öfters mal im Stream sind, die wissen's.
Ich bin kein großartiger Voice
Assistant Fan. Die einzige,
das einzige Anwendungszweck, den ich sehe,
was beispielsweise Siri oder so am
iPhone hat, ist, wenn man Auto fährt. Der Rest
find ich, äh, immer
noch per Knopfdruck oder
App Interface oder sonst was, find ich besser.
Äh, sagt dein Chef was dagegen,
so lange im Urlaub zu Stück zu nehmen? Mein Chef
hat gesagt, wir dürfen keinen Urlaub
mit ins nächste Jahr nehmen. Was soll ich denn machen?
Der kann ja schlecht sagen,
du darfst keinen Urlaub mit ins nächste Jahr nehmen,
aber du darfst auch deinen Urlaub nicht in diesem Jahr
nehmen. Also,
wie soll das funktionieren, ne?
Also muss ich das ja
machen. Ist sieben Wochen nicht
overkill? Ne.
Wenn's nach mir geht, würde ich auf Twitter Trends
wetten, Geld machen und nie wieder arbeiten gehen.
Excellent. Ne, ist nicht overkill.
Sieben Wochen ist top.
Kann ich endlich mal ein bisschen hier was machen.
Okay, ich glaube, ich habe nichts übersehen.
Das ist korrekt.
True, 0 W.
Wieso wettest du nicht auf Twitter Trends? Ja, weil's
keine Seite gibt, wo man das machen kann.
Wie gesagt, gäbe es eine Seite,
wo man auf Twitter Trends
wetten kann, wäre ich schon reich.
An Weihnachten wird Black Mesa zu Ende
gestreamt. An Weihnachten machen wir
doch Kobol, dachte ich.
Also, ich gucke jetzt mal kurz in meine Einkaufsliste.
So.
Genau. So, also,
was ich mir noch bestellen wollte,
ich habe mir hier letztens diesen Switch gekauft.
Ist auch so ein China
Zigbee Ding. Hast du schon mal
Outlast gezockt? Äh, Outlast?
Outlast?
Ist das dieses Spiel mit der Kamera?
Es gab mal ganz früher
so ein Adventure Spiel, das ähnlich hieß, aber
das glaube ich nicht, dass du das meinst, ne?
Ne, nö.
Ich bin kein großartiger Horror Game
Horror Game Fan.
Also,
ist nicht so mein Genre, so.
Wisst ihr, an welches Spiel ich gedacht habe?
Ich habe an Outcast gedacht.
Falls das Game noch jemand kennt.
Also, ich weiß, ihr werdet
jetzt wahrscheinlich sagen, MonkaS,
was für eine Grafik, aber
die Grafik war für die damalige
Zeit extrem poggers
von der Landschaft her.
Äh, ne, das ist das Remake.
Outcast
Videogame, ja, hier.
Also, ähm,
ich weiß, für die heutige
Zeit sieht das übelst kacke aus und so,
aber überlegt euch mal, 1998
war das die mit
Abstand hübscheste Landschafts-
Grafik, die man je gesehen hat.
Ja, so sah das damals aus,
natürlich im Vergleich
zu heute übelst kacke,
aber landschaftsmäßig war das damals
echt Next Gen, ja.
Und es lief richtig schlecht.
Ich glaube, die maximale Auflösung war 640x480
oder so. Ähm,
das einzige Horrorgame, ich weiß aber nicht, ob es
als Horrorgame durchgeht, was ich gespielt habe,
ist 4. Also 4-1.
2 habe ich auch gespielt, das war aber kacke.
Und 3 habe ich mir dann gar nicht mehr
gegeben. Aber der erste, der war wirklich
poggers.
Also, wer das nicht gespielt hat, sollte das unbedingt
nochmal spielen. Ähm,
es sieht auch für die heutige Zeit noch ganz brauchbar aus.
Also, es geht.
Es sah für damals halt
verdammt gut aus, aber das geht für die heutige Zeit.
Also, es sieht immer noch ganz gut aus.
Ich muss mir überlegen, das ist von 2005.
Also, da kannst du wirklich nichts sagen.
Ich soll mir eine was kaufen?
Was ist das?
Du solltest dir unbedingt eine
Ha- Kann ich
danach suchen oder ist das Toss?
Wenn ich da jetzt danach suche
und es ist irgendwie, irgendwie ne, ne, ne,
keine Ahnung, äh,
Anime, äh,
Lollipuppe oder so.
Man weiß, man weiß ja nicht,
wobei, der Sbarro, da können wir bestimmt
sagen, wenn das hier irgendwas anstößiges wäre.
Der kennt ja in dem einen Bereich zumindest gut aus, glaub ich.
Ähm,
alles okay, gut.
Also, ach so,
ne Lampe, okay.
Okay, und warum soll ich mir die
kaufen? Was? Du solltest
dir unbedingt noch eine kaufen, damit's
bei dir nie wieder finster bleibt.
Ist die so super hell oder was?
Power Star.
Ganz schön dicke Kabel.
Da geht bestimmt ordentlich was
durch. Was ist denn so
die Lautstärke? Äh,
Lautstärke, was lab ich denn?
Leuchtstärke.
Wobei, bei dem
Ding weiß man nicht, vielleicht hat das auch ne Lautstärke.
Alter!
200.000
Lumen. Wohlgemerkt,
die Lampe, hier,
die ich hier grade anhab, die hat
1100.
Alter, das ist
ja, das ist ja private
Sonne. Und wo schließt man das dran an?
Ist das, ist das ne, ne, ne, ist das ne
E27-Fassung oder was ist das?
Ne, E40. Wo kriegt
man denn ein E40-Sockel her?
Dafür hab ich doch nicht mal nen Anschluss.
Aber das ist echt
brutals hell.
Was verbraucht die denn?
Wo steht denn dann, was die braucht?
Oh! Kriegt man das über?
Was ist denn das?
Also ich mein, mit solchen normalen Steckdosen kriegt man
glaub ich 230 Volt, maximal
16 Ampere. Okay, reicht. Es reicht.
Oder, ne, 10, oder?
16?
Ne, 16, oder?
Aus so ner normalen Steckdose maximal.
Reicht auf jeden Fall.
Aber das ist schon ordentlich.
Das ist wirklich heftig.
Die wird bestimmt auch
ein bisschen warm. Könnt ich mir vorstellen.
Ich glaub, die greift man nach so ner halben
Stunde nicht mehr an. Nach ner halben
Stunde hat die wahrscheinlich eh das Haus weggestrahlt.
Die braucht bestimmt nen Kühler,
ja. Da musstet ihr erstmal
vom Bauer so nen
Flüssig-Stickstoff-CPU-Kühler holen,
dass du die Lampe betreiben
kannst.
Dann geht das.
Keine aktive Kühlung.
Okay. Gut, ähm,
unabhängig davon, ich glaube, das ist
ein bisschen zu over-sized, so für meine
Anwendungszwecke.
Da könnte ich wahrscheinlich hier gar nicht sitzen, in dem
Raum. Die würd mich an die
Wand strahlen. So.
Also. Kommen wir mal
zu der eigentlich Einkaufsgeschichte zurück. Also,
davon wollt ich mir noch ein paar bestellen. Wo
kann man einstellen? Prime?
Prime? Prime
Shipping? Gibt's da grad
keine per Prime Shipping? Seh ich das richtig?
Ich hab
mal ein paar Prime Shipping gekriegt.
Anzeige ist raus. Was soll das hier?
Kein Prime Shipping.
Die kommen aus China.
Och, nee. Oder? Kommen gar
nicht aus China. Achso, Moment,
doch, die kommen aus China. 8. bis
17. Dezember, ich glaub, es geht los.
0w.
Aber Free Shipping ist nicht
automatisch Prime. Ja,
das geht.
Muss mal kurz gucken, was ich dafür bezahlt hab.
Weil, das Ding, ich hab
mir jetzt einen bestellt, und ihr wisst ja,
Konto wechseln.
Ah, Mist.
Ich muss jetzt 2-Faktor-Authentifizierung
machen bei Amazon.
Moment.
Da muss ich mich erstmal bei Amazon. Ah, nee, mein Passwort.
Das war jetzt aus dem Kopf weg. Leute,
mein Amazon-Account wurde gehackt letztens.
Nein, stimmt nicht.
So halb. Ich dachte, er wurde
gehackt.
Ich hab eine Mail gekriegt.
Unautorisiertes Login aus
Irland. Da hab ich gedacht,
what? Unautorisiertes
Login aus
Irland?
Was ist da los?
Und Amazon
ist ja ein bisschen rückständig, was das Ganze
angeht.
Du hast bei Amazon keinerlei
Möglichkeit, in der History zu gucken,
wann von welcher IP Login war,
was auch ziemlich fail ist.
Und dann hab ich mal ein bisschen nachgeforscht und hab
festgestellt, Moment, Moment, Moment mal.
Sonntag, 14 Uhr
26, aus
Irland? Aus dem
Amazon Cloud Player?
So, und dann hab ich mal bei mir in die
Browser-Historie geguckt und hab festgestellt, der
Amazon Cloud Player ist, wenn man
Musik-Amazon-Playlist direkt aufmacht,
ohne über Amazon zu gehen, ist dann, da meldet
sich das als Amazon Cloud Player an.
Und um 14 Uhr 26 Sonntags,
da war ich gerade mit dem Stream fertig,
vor Viertelstunde vorher, und hab in
meiner History geguckt, ich war das selbst.
Ich war nämlich
exakt laut meiner History, 14 Uhr 26,
auf meiner Ärzte-
Playlist bei Amazon Music
und hab mich neu eingeloggt.
Warum das allerdings unautorisierter
Zugriff aus Irland
war? Keine Ahnung.
Ich vermute einfach mal, dass das
Geo, wie heißt das?
Geo...
Geolocation rückwärts auflösen
da von Amazon nicht
richtig funktioniert hat und meinte, meine
Unity-Media-IP ist
in Irland.
Aber ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich hab schon ein bisschen
geschluckt
und daraufhin hab ich mein
Amazon-Passwort geändert und
2-Faktor-Authentifizierung eingeschaltet.
Deswegen kann ich jetzt nicht
nachgucken auf der anderen Seite, was ich
bezahlt hab für.
Weil ich mein neues Amazon-Passwort
nicht weiß. Da steht eben
im Key-Pass drinne
und
keine Chance.
Genau, zumindest davon hab ich mir
nen Switch gekauft und ich muss sagen, ich find die wirklich
sehr nice.
Ich hab mir den gekauft mit
3 Knöppen.
Also insgesamt sind 6 Buttons.
Also das sind jeweils
1 Button. Das ist
ein Switch, der geht über SIGBEE
und je nachdem,
wenn man den in seine Heimautomatisierung
einbindet, kann man damit
die unterschiedlichen Funktionen machen.
Also der Switch unterstützt,
sag ich Switch, der Schalter,
der unterstützt jeweils
Einfachklick, Doppelklick, Dreifachklick
und
Taste halten. Das heißt, man kann damit
richtig schöne, viele Funktionen umsetzen.
Was man
zum Beispiel
als erstes, was wir angenommen haben, ich möchte
den Rollo hoch und runter machen, dort wo ich den Motor drin hab,
könnte ich sagen, Long Press
hier drauf, ist
Rollo runter, Long Press hier drauf, ist
Rollo hoch, aber zum Beispiel
kurzer Press da drauf
ist, sagen wir,
Licht dimmen und hier ist Licht
so. Ihr könnt es euch vorstellen.
Also man hat damit ziemlich viele
Automatisierungsmöglichkeiten.
So und auf die Frage, sind die mit Batterie
oder zum Anschließen, die sind mit Batterie
Ich bin da
auch so hin und her gerissen, ob ich es gut oder schlecht
finde, aber letztendlich mit Batterie
hat den Vorteil, du musst den so runter rumfummeln.
Was die aber wirklich gut gemacht haben, ist,
die haben hier so eine Halterung dabei.
So, man kann den einmal aus der Halterung rausnehmen
und dann so eine Art Fernbedienung verwenden.
Da hat man so eine Art Zigbee-Fernbedienung, wenn man das will.
Oder aber es gibt so ein magnetisches
so ein magnetisches
Sockel, so ein magnetischer Sockel, den kann
man entweder an die Wand schrauben, an die Wand
kleben oder, da sind zwei Magnete
drin, zum Beispiel an einem Türrahmen
hängen. Und ich hab das Ding jetzt
am Eingang zum Wohnzimmer hängen.
Mit diesem
Magnetrahmen an der Tür,
wenn man da jetzt drauf drückt, kann man irgendwelche
Aktionen auslösen.
Also, aktuell
verwende ich den für nichts, aber ich finde den gut.
Einziger Nachteil ist,
ich zeige euch mal, wie der Batteriewechsel funktioniert.
Der ist abenteuerlich.
Ja, ich glaube, der hier
zeigt das. Also,
das Ding hat mit Abstand
den schlechtesten
Batteriewechsel-Workflow
aller Zeiten. So etwas habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
Passt mal auf, man muss das hier
aufmachen.
Also, man muss das hier schon erstmal halb abbrechen,
um Batterien zu wechseln.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Oh, ey, ich brech das ab.
Ich weiß jetzt schon, dass ich das abbreche.
Also, man muss quasi den Schalter
halb abbrechen, um die Batterie zu wechseln.
Was ist das überhaupt für ein
Big Brain Plastiktool, was der da hat?
Guckt euch das mal an. Ich mach das kaputt, ey.
So, da muss er das abreißen davon.
So, und das war's
noch nicht. Wer jetzt denkt, da drunter
ist die Batterie,
der weit gefehlt. So einfach ist es noch nicht.
Das ist so ein iFixit-Ding.
Da müsste ich das in meinem Set eigentlich auch
drin haben.
So, und jetzt muss man noch aufschrauben.
Also, das ist wirklich der schlechteste
Batteriewechsel-Vorgang aller Zeiten.
Aufschrauben?
Geht noch weiter, geht noch weiter.
Das war's noch nicht.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne. So einfach ist es nicht.
Ich mein, mittlerer
Schalter raus aufschrauben wäre jetzt ja auch schon...
Das wäre auch zu einfach, ne? Ehrlich,
Chat, das kann nicht sein.
Jetzt muss er erst noch den Rahmen halb
kaputt machen.
Also, ich werd's
definitiv kaputt machen, das weiß ich jetzt schon.
Ich mein, man hätte einfach
ein Fach auf der Unterseite machen können.
Warum hat man nicht einfach ein Fach zum
Aufmachen auf der Unterseite gemacht?
Warum baut man das so?
Ich kann mir nur zwei Sachen erklären,
warum man das so baut.
Erstens ist, die Chinesen waren
unfähig, ordentlich zu bauen.
Gar nicht so unwahrscheinlich, wenn man sich manche Sachen anguckt,
die da herkommen, an Technik
Gedöns. Oh, jetzt kommen die Leute
wieder, Max, du bist ultra rassistisch, kack,
kack, hier, das kannst du nicht
sagen, Chinesen bauen schlechte Dinger.
Also, ich hab schon so viele chinesische Dinger
gekauft, die höchst fragwürdig waren.
Doch, ich kann das sagen.
Oder, das zweite ist,
die wollen nicht, dass man das auswechselt.
Ich tippe auf zweiteres.
Also, ich tippe auf ne Kombination aus beiden.
Ich glaube, die Chinesen, die das
designt haben, haben noch
nicht so die Ultra-Design-Erfahrung
in solchen Dingern.
Und, sie fanden es ganz gut,
weil man dann wahrscheinlich einen neuen Schalter kauft
und es nicht selbst auswechselt.
Die Batterien, ich glaube, die halten
relativ lang. Letztendlich
verbraucht es ja nur Energie, wenn man draufdrückt
bei einem Schalter.
Und ein bisschen Eigenentladung.
Zigbee braucht allgemein nicht
viel. Na, zumindest, er ist immer noch
nicht fertig, er hat das Ding immer noch nicht offen.
Guckt euch das mal an.
So, jetzt hat er es.
Jetzt hat er es.
Das ist wirklich witzlos.
So, und da hinten ist jetzt...
Moment, jetzt muss man das noch rausmachen.
Und da hinten ist die Batterie drin.
So, und jetzt erklärt mir mal,
welcher
Big-Brain-Design-Chinaman
gedacht hat,
da hinten kann man kein Fach dran machen.
Die Batterie ist legit
an der Rückseite des Gehäuses.
Das heißt, du hättest
einfach ne Klappe dran machen können
und schon könntest du
die Batterie austauschen.
Das ist übrigens ne gute Idee.
Hinten ein Loch reinschneiden.
Ja, finde ich sogar ne gute Idee.
Weil man macht das Ding eh an die Wand.
Das sieht man nicht.
Was würdest du als Wohnzimmergerät
für einen dummen TV vorschlagen,
wenn man keinen Google oder Amazon
oder Google Account damit verwenden will?
Ich denke, die beste Lösung ist einfach
einen PC mit Windows hinzustellen.
Achso, einen dummen TV.
Was spricht gegen einen Firestick?
Die kannst du im Zweifelsfall
auch so verwenden.
Deep-Loaded Amazon.
Hat halt den Vorteil,
du musst dich um nichts großartig kümmern.
Ich persönlich bin ja
Fan vom Shield-Tablet.
Ja gut, klar,
der Firestick muss ins WLAN.
Du brauchst ja irgendeine Verbindung,
dass du Sachen streamen kannst da drauf.
Nutzt du Alexa Smart Home-mäßig?
Ne, bin kein großartiger
Voice Assistant-Fan.
Ja, aber guck mal,
eine riesen Akte, die Batterie zu wechseln.
Das ist echt witzlos.
Mega-Fail.
Das machst du einmal, danach ist das Ding kaputt.
Und ich habe ja eh so ein Händchen für sowas.
Ich mache es wahrscheinlich beim ersten Mal
schon broken danach,
wenn ich das aufgemacht habe.
Aber müsst ihr zugeben, Chat,
der Wechselvorgang ist wirklich
ziemlich keck.
Tribble you.
Ah, Moment, ich habe Amazon zugemacht.
Wenn ich das bestelle.
So, ich bestelle mir mal,
nicht Apple.
Fällt mir auf, dass es Opel heißt.
Also quasi, so wie Apple,
nur mit O.
Warum auch immer.
Moment, die gibt es bis 16.
16 bis 19.
Ah, das ist okay.
5 Stück left, bam, easy.
Moment, 11 Stück?
Warum habe ich 11 Sachen im...
Okay, also wenn die,
wenn man da Bedenken hat mit den Firesticks,
gut verstehen kann, ihr kennt mich,
ich bin auch jemand, der
nichts,
nichts gerne
da mit Originalfirma betreibt,
dann,
genau, Nvidia Shield
ist auch eine Option.
Also, du brauchst kein Nvidia
GPU, also du brauchst,
wenn du zu deinem Nvidia Shield,
wenn du Gamestream machen willst,
okay, aber wenn du einfach nur
Android verwenden willst,
sei es jetzt
Netflix,
YouTube, meinetwegen auch
die komische ZDF, ARD,
Media Gedöns, oder
Fernseh gucken willst, über irgendwie
nen Stick,
oder nen TV Head and Linux
Kiste, ich mache es ja,
ich habe es ja selbst,
ich habe das ja selbst mit dem Shield TV.
Ah.
Der Fernseher, den ich hier habe,
der hat auch nen Android drauf,
aber das verwende ich nicht,
ich verwende
die Oberfläche, das ist die Oberfläche vom
Shield TV, hier, da steht es.
Das ist noch das alte Shield TV.
Nicht diese komische Wurst, die es jetzt gibt.
Äh, Zenigma Code habe ich auch.
Ich habe ein paar Shelly Ones,
die kannst du mit dem Lichtschalter schalten.
Warum habe ich hier so viel?
Achso, das ist noch vom letzten Mal drin.
Moment, das habe ich alles schon
bestellt.
Außer das, das habe ich noch nicht bestellt,
das lasse ich mal drin.
Was ist ein Shield TV?
Das Ding, was ich eben gezeigt habe, hier.
Was ist das?
Das ist
ein Android, das ist eine Android TV Box
von Nvidia. Allerdings auch gleichzeitig
die teuerste Android TV Box.
Aber wie ich finde, die beste.
Es gibt noch ein paar Alternativen, es gibt diese
Ronco Geschichte, habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Das Billigste ist, sich einen Fire Stick zu kaufen
von Amazon und zu deploaten.
Aber kann ich verstehen, wenn man das nicht will,
der wird bestimmt die ein oder anderen Sachen nach Hause schicken.
Und Cody auf einem
Raspberry Pi finde ich kacke.
Raspberry Pi ist für Mediasachen
übelst laggy und
kacke einfach nur.
Ich habe es mal probiert, konntest du komplett
vergessen. Konntest du komplett
knicken, das war so eklig.
Der M-Core.
Also ein Shield TV ist, finde ich, das Beste.
Das aktuelle Shield TV sieht
leider ein bisschen Fail aus.
Das Shield Pro sieht jetzt so aus,
wie das, was ich habe. Und das normale
Shield TV ist so ein komischer Zigarettenanzünder.
Weiß nicht so genau, was sich Nvidia
dabei gedacht hat, bei diesem Design.
Das kannst du nicht mal ordentlich hinlegen, irgendwie.
Und Fernsehgucken
mache ich halt auch nicht
über Shield TV direkt.
Ich habe noch eine
Single Board Computer
Box, die steht daneben.
So eine hier, steht daneben.
Mit einer Festplatte drin.
Das ist so fix und fertig, da kann man eine Festplatte anschließen.
Da habe ich einen Linux drauf installiert
und hier am USB-Port hängt
ein Dual-Tuner.
WinTV
Dual-Tuner-Stick.
Über den kann man Fernsehgucken
und Fernsehaufnehmen.
Und hier habe ich
auf dem Shield TV habe ich noch Kodi drauf.
Und da streamt dann hier die Aufnahmen
von dem Ding. Funktioniert wunderbar.
Ja, selbst über
Shield Tablet wollte ich das Ganze nicht machen.
Da ist es schwierig, TV-Sticks
zum Laufen zu bekommen und
dann brauchst du noch ein Backend,
das die Aufnahmen macht und eine Festplatte an Shield TV
und sonst was. Da habe ich mir gedacht, komm
machst du lieber noch eine billige
zweite Kiste hin.
Ist auch mal ganz gut.
Weil wenn
dann das Shield TV mal verrecken sollte, ist nicht alles
weg.
Oder zumindest nicht alles erstmal
nicht benutzbar.
Die Kombi läuft jetzt schon seit 2 Jahren
oder 3 Jahren echt
ohne Probleme.
Eher 2 Jahre. Wir haben es ja im Stream zusammen.
Wir haben es ja installiert damals.
Matt, wie ich...
Du musst mich da gar nicht überzeugen.
Ich glaub das dir sofort, dass der
Amazon Stick Sachen nach Hause schickt.
Sofort. Das würde mich eher wundern,
wenn der Amazon Stick keine Sachen nach Hause schickt.
Schon gesehen die Steckdose...
Was? Ernsthaft? Wirklich?
Schon gesehen die Steckdosen,
die du umgeflasht hast, hättest du nicht öffnen brauchen.
Gibt für den Raspberry Pi ein Tool,
das das Motor OTA flasht.
Echt? Also sicher?
Also ich mein, du meinst wahrscheinlich Tuya Convert.
Aber Tuya Convert
geht nicht mit den Steckdosen, die ich hab.
Du meinst das hier, ne?
Der Eichler ist am Start. 15 Monate.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Excellent. 15 Monate.
Das ist ja schon richtig...
Was macht denn dieser Pikmin-Typ hier?
Das sieht aus...
Das ist der Pikmin-Typ, oder?
Das sieht original aus wie der Pikmin-Mensch.
Ja, also...
Wer hat es eben im Chat geschrieben?
Der Aris...
Ich geh mal davon aus, du meinst das hier, ne?
Also wenn du das hier meinst,
das ging mit den Steckdosen nicht.
Gibt's ja eigentlich Battlefield 3 manchmal zu sehen.
Ja, tatsächlich. Ab und zu mal schon.
Das geht mit den Steckdosen nicht.
Amazon lügt.
Also sprich, das was bei Amazon
zu den Steckdosen steht,
dass es damit geht, ist alte Firmware.
Es sei denn, du hast noch was aktuelleres
gefunden, was das kann.
Da wär ich natürlich dann sehr daran interessiert,
zu wissen, was das ist.
Google Photos Speicher.
Google Photos ist wohl bald nicht mehr...
Was? Kennst du noch Alternativen?
Am besten Unlimited Cloud...
Also Unlimited Cloud Speicher kenn ich nix.
Aber wenn das so hart auf hart kommt,
dass wir das Archiv irgendwo anders
archivieren müssen,
dann gucken wir mal, was irgendwo so eine Storage-Box kostet.
Wird auch nicht die Welt sein.
Das kostet grad bei der
Hetzner-Server-Auktion Speicherplatz.
Zeig ich mal her.
Bam, bababam, bababam.
Wie viel braucht man in Sbarro?
Nein, das ist zu teuer.
Null W.
Im Zweifelsfall kaufen wir irgendwie 5 Euro
Google Drive oder so.
Cheap...
Ich hab mal richtig
billige Storage-Server gefunden.
Die waren aber so richtig fell mit
NAT davor und sowas.
Cheap Storage...
VPS...
Was gibt's denn da so?
Time VPS for you? Oh, klingt sehr vertrauenserweckend.
Alles klar.
Data Storage, okay.
Ehrlich? Wow!
Monka S.
Ähm...
Bisschen teuer vielleicht?
Bisschen teuer.
Ja, dann müssen wir mal schauen, was da möglichst günstig ist.
Aber Sbarro, sag, wenn's geht,
bisschen früher Bescheid, dass wir uns was überlegen können.
Du kannst ja mal gucken, wie groß das Archiv
aktuell ist.
Okay, gucken wir mal weiter. Also, ich guck mal in meine Einkaufsliste.
Also, äh, DOR-Sensors
äh, nicht DOR-Sensors, äh,
Schalter haben wir.
Das, äh,
mit der Lampe hatte ich euch gezeigt.
Ach ja, übrigens,
äh, ich hab euch ja grad,
ich hab euch ja grad diese Lampe gezeigt, die noch,
die neben RGB-LED auch Infrarot
kann für das Nachtsichtgerät.
Und was, was sich jetzt mal
wieder gelohnt hat, ist,
ich hab ja meine Kamera auch mit Custom,
mit Custom-Firmware geflasht,
nämlich mit der hier.
Guck mal, ob ich euch ne Kamera
zeigen kann, was die für Möglichkeiten hat.
Das ist nämlich richtig nice.
Da kannst du ne 20-Dollar-Cam
äh, richtig Feature-mäßig
richtig aufbohren.
Muss mal gucken, dass ich euch die aus dem Keller
zeige, weil da kann ich nix leaken.
Nein, das ist die, äh,
das ist nicht die aus dem Keller.
Das ist die aus dem Keller. Excellent.
Genau, ähm,
das ist die Custom-Firmware,
die ich auf meiner Kamera drauf hab.
Und das hat halt den riesen Vorteil,
dass man wieder mal keine Hersteller-Cloud braucht,
keine Hersteller-App braucht.
Und dass man auch, äh,
über die API ziemlich viele
Funktionen fernsteuern kann, zum Beispiel
Infrarot-Filter an-aus,
Infrarot-LED an-aus,
äh, Nachtsichtmodus an-aus und sowas.
Zeig euch mal,
was man da alles einstellen kann.
Wohlgemerkt, wir reden hier von ner 25-Dollar-Kamera,
ja. Das ist jetzt die, die ich im Keller
hängen hab. Kann ich euch am besten zeigen,
weil, äh, stört euch mal nicht, dass
da Kamera-3D-Printer
dransteht. Das ist kein 3D-Printer,
wie ihr vielleicht seht, ja. Es ist, äh,
natürlich ist es Root 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
was sonst. Ja, also was dir alles
Mögliche einstellen kannst.
Äh, kannst einstellen,
ähm,
ganze Videogeschichten kannst du einstellen,
was du haben willst, äh,
Nachtsichtmodus, sonst was, äh,
Infrarot-LED, Infrarot-Filter,
automatische Nachterkennung,
die LEDs kann man vorne aus-
Die Motion Detection ist übelst kacke,
die würd ich da gar nicht, äh,
anschalten. Das Ding hat
einen RTSP-Stream, einen MJPEG-Stream,
kann über MQTT Status versenden,
Status empfangen, kann Sound abspielen,
kann, äh, Mails
und Telegram-Nachrichten schicken, wenn es
Bewegung erkannt hat und sowas. Also,
das hat wirklich richtig viele
nice Features. Achso, ja,
hin- und herschwenken kann man die Kamera auch
übers Webinterface. Das hat richtig-
LED-Configuration, was auch immer,
ach, genau. Das hat richtig coole Features,
die man sonst im Leben
nicht bei, ähm,
einer 25-Euro-Kamera
findet, ja. Ist schon nicht schlecht.
Irgendwie gesagt, das ist jetzt, äh,
man macht das ja über einen RTSP-Stream und
nicht über diese komische, dieses komische
Webfrontend hier. Max, bist du es?
Kommt drauf an.
Ich bin mir noch nicht
sicher, ob ich's bin. Vielleicht
bin ich's. Es wäre möglich.
Es ist im Bereich des Möglichen, dass ich's bin.
Ähm, ja,
die Motion Detection ist übel- ist
schlecht, ja. Also, das
packt das Ding nicht. Das ist total ausgelastet
dabei. Das schafft vielleicht ein Bild pro
Sekunde, wenn's hochkommt.
Da ist unsere selbstprogrammierte
Motion Detection viel besser.
Wie heißt die Cam? Also, das hab ich auf
ner Wisecam-Pan laufen.
Aber du musst gucken, dass du die jetzt nicht aktuell
kaufst, weil aktuell sind
die viel zu teuer.
Viel, viel zu teuer.
Ich hab 25 Dollar bezahlt
damals für. 25
Dollar. So, hier,
guck mal, bei Wish. Kann man bei Wish
kaufen. Ich hab die 25 Dollar, ich hab
mir nen, ey, kein Fünferpack.
Ich glaub, drei Stück davon und drei Stück
von den anderen hab ich mir bei Amazon.com
bestellt. Da hab ich zwar insgesamt
äh, glaub,
20, 20 Dollar nochmal für
Versand und Import bezahlt, aber insgesamt
war das viel günstiger.
Also, das lohnt sich überhaupt nicht.
Ja, Wild Alfred, schön, dass du den
Wich hergefunden hast. Nice.
Ähm, aber viel zu teuer.
Was ist mit denen los? Das Ding ist niemals
80 Euro wert. Das ist ne total
billige Schrottcam. Das einzig
Gute daran war, dass sie schwenkbar
ist. Äh, Custom-Firmware,
Support hat. Also, naja, Support.
Es gibt ne Custom-Firmware dafür. Ist ja nicht so, dass
das offiziell supportet wär. Und dass sie billig
ist. Für 80 Euro gibt's viel bessere
Kameras. 17 Euro ist okay.
Also, sind die, sind die noch
bei, sind die noch
bei Sinnen? Warum soll ich da, warum soll
ich 70 Euro kosten
beim offiz... Ja, okay. Ja,
Leute.
Warum, warum ist das bei Amazon
com so teuer? Hä?
Das muss ich mir jetzt nochmal angucken.
37 Dollar, okay.
Chips to Germany. Wird das nochmal
extra berechnet? Äh,
Add to Cart? Checkout?
Ja. Ach nee,
da kommt noch, warum ist das so teuer?
Was ist denn mit Amazon los? Ich mein,
im offiziellen Shop kostet 29 Euro.
Warum soll ich bei Amazon 8, 9
Euro mehr dafür bezahlen? Einfach, weil's Amazon
ist, oder wie?
Shippen, shippen die nach Germany?
Shippen die nach Germany?
Kann man, das ist ne, das ist ne gute
Frage. Die Gedanken hab ich mir nämlich auch gemacht.
Kann man nicht eine x-beliebige
1080p USB-Webcam
für 15 Euro von Amazon hernehmen und
an einen Raspberry Pi anschließen. Doch,
du kannst ne USB-Webcam an
einen Raspberry Pi anschließen, du kannst aber auch einfach
dir die jeweilige Raspberry Pi Kamera kaufen.
Der Nachteil daran ist,
du kannst es nicht drehen,
also du kannst nicht pan,
pan, tilt machen. Du kannst es
nicht drehen und neigen. Du kannst
nen Raspberry Pi nicht in ein gescheites Gehäuse
mit ner Kamera packen zusammen. Äh,
wasserdicht ist das, okay, wasserdicht
ist die hier auch nicht. Wasserabweis ist
das ganze schon mal gar nicht. Und,
ähm, die Kombination
Raspberry Pi Kamera und Infrarot-LED
Nachtsicht
ist auch nicht
so einfach. Also,
das bessere Paket ist tatsächlich,
finde ich, so ne
30 Euro Billig-Cam
mit Custom-Firmware. Aber nicht,
also was, die, die, die haben hier total Arsch offen,
30 Euro bei Amazon, ich glaub's geht los. Äh,
ne, 70 Euro bei Amazon, ich glaub's geht los.
30 Dollar ist genau das,
was, was ich sag, ja, das ist
die oberste Grenze, vergiss es.
So, lass mal gucken, Shipping,
zählt das schon nach Germany?
Okay, sagen wir mal, ich bestell
5, äh,
und dann checken wir out nach
Germany. Kann man das irgendwie
berechnen lassen?
Ah, fuck!
Die shippen, die
shippen nur nach Kokona.
Warum macht man denn sowas?
Das ist zu viel Freedom für mich.
Ja, dann bleibt dann doch nix anderes übrig.
Wird Amazon dann wenigstens größer?
Oder günstiger, wenn man viel bestellt?
Was Import angeht?
Ja, ja, weiter.
Äh, und was steht jetzt, was es
Import kostet?
Das steht nur da, wenn ich mich einlogge, ne?
Na, super.
Weil wenn das, wenn das hier, und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher,
dass es nicht pro Kamera zählt,
weil sonst hätte es sich damals nicht gelohnt,
wo ich es bestellt hab, ähm,
weil wenn das hier wirklich pro Kamera
ist, dann lohnt sich das natürlich absolut nicht.
So, so wird halt auch mal
schnell aus der 29 Dollar
Webcam, oder aus der
25, aus der 29 Dollar
Kamera, ChinaCam, wird halt auch mal
schnell ein 60 Euro Teil.
Das ist halt, das ist halt Fail.
Das Gute ist,
wenn man so Sachen über Amazon bestellt, mit diesem
Amazon Import, äh,
das Gute ist, dass das nicht beim Zoll hängen bleibt.
Weil wenn du was aus den USA bestellst,
du kannst, du kannst eigentlich dich drauf
verlassen, dass der Kram beim Zoll liegen bleibt.
Die Ami-Hersteller sind
nicht in der Lage, diese
Zollsachen richtig zu deklarieren.
Ich musste jedes Mal, ich weiß nicht, wie es bei euch
ist, Chat, ob ihr das öfters mal gemacht habt,
oder auch schon da schlechte Erfahrungen mitgebracht habt,
ich musste jedes Mal, wenn ich aus den USA
was bestellt hab zum Zoll, jedes Mal,
die kriegen das einfach nicht hin.
Die Chinesen machen das besser.
Die schreiben einfach was drauf, was
nicht stimmt. Und schon geht das einfach
durch den Zoll durch.
AliExpress verschippt,
was weiß ich, schickt das dann über Rotterdam,
über die Niederlande mit PostNL
nach Deutschland und schreibt bei
300€ Elektronikartikel
drauf
12€ Elektro-Teile. Easy.
Die Chinesen kennen da halt nix.
Und im Zweifelsfall bist du ja auch
nicht der Gearschte, sondern der chinesische Hersteller.
Weil du, du, du
willst das ja nicht, dass da irgendwie
Sachen falsch deklariert sind.
Wie gesagt, ich weise das alles
von mir, das würde ich nie im Leben
gutheißen, ja.
Was, Gerüchte über Geiselnahme bei Ubisoft?
What the fuck?
Was? Ernsthaft?
Was?
Bo, ich seh da nix.
Chat, gebetet mich.
Ja, also das, also
man kann sich zwar über die, über die
Ubisoft Spiele ausregen, aber das
die, also, das
äh, muss
ja wirklich nicht sein.
Was ist denn das für ne Seite?
Ja, das ist von eben.
Was ist das für ne Seite? Hab ich noch nie, hab ich noch nie gehört.
Canadian News. Ach stimmt,
das, die, die, die sind ja hier,
das ist ja, Baguette,
vergesse ich immer wieder bei Ubisoft.
WTF? Was da los?
Was ist da los?
Äh, äh, dutzend People,
äh, äh, dutzende Leute werden, äh,
als Geisel gehalten bei Ubisoft.
In Montreal?
Polizei ist am Start.
Krasser Scheiß, was da los?
The fuck? WTF?
Ubisoft.
Fuck, was da los?
Die meisten sind zum Glück beim Homeoffice, ja.
Ist Ubisoft nicht Rainbow Six?
Nee, ich mach jetzt keinen blöden Spruch.
Das wär jetzt, nein, das muss ich mir jetzt
verkneifen. Ähm, aber ich hoffe wirklich,
dass das alles glimpflich ausgehen.
Krasser Scheiß, ey.
Was da rauskommt.
Definitiv nicht Poggers.
Ja, hoffentlich sind nicht so viele da. Die meisten
dürfen ja wirklich Homeoffice machen.
Mal gespannt, was da rauskommt.
Vielleicht ist es ja auch nicht so schlimm, wie es auf den ersten Blick aussieht.
Vielleicht gab's ja auch nur irgendwie,
frag mich nicht, irgendwie, ähm,
falsche, falsche, falsche
Bombenalarm oder irgendwie sowas.
Keine Ahnung, mal gucken. Also, äh,
ich hoffe ja nicht, dass denen irgendwas passiert.
Das finde ich auch immer
teilweise bescheuert, ne. Es, es gibt ja
Leute auf Twitter, also, grade, grade auf Twitter,
Twitter ist so, was das Social-Media-Sachen angeht,
das Allerschlimmste in dieser Richtung. Ähm,
die, die machen sich jetzt da drüber lustig,
so nach dem Motto, ah, hier, guck mal hier,
Assassin's Creed hat gesagt jetzt, äh,
die haben sich anders verdient, blablabla.
Also nur, weil einer ein Scheiß-Game macht,
äh,
schießt hier im Licht, dass aber irgendein Geiselnahme erschossen wird
oder so. Also die haben teilweise ein bisschen Dachschaden.
Social-Media-Leute.
Naja, also ich hoffe, dass das alles gut ausgeht.
Ja, schauen wir mal, was rauskommt.
Okay,
machen wir mal weiter. Wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Ähm, ich,
bei euch gibt's doch manchmal,
ja, siehst du,
in meinen Vorschlägen hab ich das sogar
laufen hier.
Ähm, ich weiß ja,
dass bei euch ein paar
Elektronik-
Leute am Start sind. Ist sowas
erlaubt, äh,
dass man E27 Lampen auf
E14 Sockel macht?
Weil die Adapter, das sind alles irgendwelche
China-Adapter. Es gibt
ja so ein paar Adapter, die
rein regularienmäßig
nicht funktionieren.
Zum Beispiel, was man nicht machen kann, ist
ähm,
ne Steckdose
mit diesem kleinen Euro-Stecker,
ich weiß nicht, ob das Ding wirklich Euro-Stecker heißt,
ihr wisst, was ich meine, diesen kleinen
2-poligen
Stecker, auf
mehrere kleine 2-polige
Stecker. Die gibt's,
die Sachen gibt's zwar von China-Herstellern,
aber das geht eigentlich nicht.
Diese, diese kleinen Dinger.
Was, GU10?
Das könnte tatsächlich GU10, ne, GU10 ist die,
also,
was man, was man nicht machen
kann, spezifikationsmäßig,
was halt auch nicht zertifiziert wird,
wenn man sowas hier hat, von diesem Stecker
auf eine Steckdose leisten, mit mehreren dieser
Steckern. Das ist nicht erlaubt.
So, und die Chinesen bauen
das trotzdem, und deswegen habe ich
mir gedacht, vielleicht ist das bei
ähm, E27 auf
E14 auch so, dass man das eigentlich gar nicht verwenden
sollte. Ich meine, es gibt
Adapter zu kaufen bei Amazon,
aber das heißt nichts, weil, das ist ein China-Hersteller,
das ist mit Sicherheit auch ein China-Hersteller,
wobei, das ist, ähm, ne, das ist
E14 auf,
stimmt überhaupt nicht, E27
das ist umgedreht, das
ist, achso, ja gut, je nachdem von welcher
Seite du guckst, passt das.
Kannst du noch mal ein Video über Dubstep erinnern? Ja,
gut, das war auch die Zeit, wo
es überall in jedem, in jedem Video
gemacht hat, wub, wub, wub, wub.
Berührungsschutz, ahja.
In, inwieweit?
Du meinst, weil das da nicht richtig
reingeht, also sprich, weil
man dann hier irgendwie an das Metall
drankommen könnte,
hier so da in die Ritze,
weil
die Lampe nicht richtig reingeht.
Ja, weil sowas brauch ich,
oder zumindest wär's nicht schlecht
zu haben.
Gucken, ob's da
ausschauen. Wieso brauchst
du's? Ja, weil die meisten
WLAN-Lampen, die halbwegs was taugen,
die sind E27 und
ich hab aber im Flur vier E16,
E14-Sockel. Am
Leuchtmittelwechsel könntest du an Metall kommen.
Ja gut, dann mach ich eh den Schalter aus vorher.
Aber ich versteh schon, was du meinst, das ist
auf jeden Fall keine schöne Bauweise
dann. Na gut, ähm,
gibt es eigentlich,
was mir grade einfällt,
gibt es ein iPad
USB-Adapter
für USB-Sticks oder so?
Bäh, sowas
gibt's ja wirklich. Weil,
ich hab mir schon öfters überlegt,
ob man's nicht irgendwie
USB-Sticks
an ein iPad dran bekommt.
Ob sowas was taugt?
Ist denn das?
Audio,
USB-C,
SD, Micro-SD und USB.
Ob das was taugt? Ich glaub
ja net, hä? Weil das wär ganz
praktisch, wenn man, äh,
das könnt ich als Weihnachtsschenk
gebrauchen. Was werden
bei Lightning nicht unterstützt? Aber das ist doch
Lightning hier. Das glaub ich
nicht, dass die, äh, dass die, ähm,
Produkte anbieten,
die keine Funktion haben, so komplett
nicht. Ja, das geht seit längerer
Zeit aber nur bedingt.
Inwieweit?
Also, weil sowas wär als Weihnachtsgeschenk für meine Mutter
nicht verkehrt. Die macht ja quasi
fast alles mit ihrem iPad.
Die macht auch ihr, ihr Steuerzeug,
kopiert die sich da übers iPad.
Was halt nervig ist, weil
die hat so nen Backup-USB-Stick,
irgend so nen uralten 1 GB, frag mich nicht.
Frag mich auch nicht warum.
Aber es ist schwierig,
das ihr dann auszureden.
Ähm,
dass sie ihr Steuerkram kopieren
könnte übers iPad.
Zum Beispiel kannst du keine Apps auf die SD
kopieren. Ah ne, das ist egal, das ist wurscht.
Bis denn, mach's gut, Sebao.
Ja doch, sowas
ist glaub ich echt nicht schlecht. Guck mal, da hast
du hast zweimal USB,
die SD-Karten braucht
kein Mensch. Ich glaub sowas bestell ich
mal, das ist ganz gut, das Weihnachtsgeschenk ist ja zu teuer.
Gut ist.
Äh, wenn du jetzt,
Moment, was? Wenn du jetzt
ein Laptop für deine Arbeit kaufen müsstest,
was würdest du dir holen?
Irgendwelche bevorzugten Marken oder Specs.
Ja so 6.000 Euro
iPad Pro, iMac Pro,
ne, wie heißen die Dinger? Ne, würd ich mir nicht holen,
Quatsch. Ähm,
ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung,
weil ich mich schon ewig nicht
mehr mit Laptops beschäftigt habe.
Auf der Arbeit aktuell
haben wir
Thinkpads, genau.
Von
Lenovo sind die ja mittlerweile.
Die sind mit
Docking Station auch echt gut.
Also die haben stabile Scharniere
am Display, das ist das erste worauf ich
immer gucke. Du hast mit der Docking Station
massig Anschlüsse.
Ein bisschen knapp mit den
Anschlüsse nur am Notebook.
Nur am Notebook hast du glaub ich maximal 2
USB. Ja.
Was Thinkpad einmal Carbon,
zeig mal her. Oh, was ist
das?
Es sieht schon mal aus wie
ein ganz traditionelles
Thinkpad. Ja, mit diesem
komischen Nippel in der
Mitte.
Das ist ja so ein Thinkpad,
das ist ja Lenovo mittlerweile.
Markenzeichen dieser komische
Huppel. Trackpoint.
Ob das jetzt
sind glaub ich Metall an der Scharniere.
Was hat man für Anschlüsse?
USB,
Strom und
zweimal USB,
ne, das ist USB,
USB, HDMI, was ist das?
Ist das ein USB-C oder ist das ein Stromanschluss?
Ich kenn das nicht genau.
USB-C?
Thunderbolt, ja.
Tja, muss ja Thunderbolt sein, weil
das USB-Forum die USB-4 Specs
so verkackt hatte. Da muss der
Intel nochmal kommen und sagen, wir machen das USB,
aber richtig. Preis scheint
sich auch halbwegs in Grenzen zu halten.
Ja, aber ich kann dir leider nichts raten.
Ich hab mich null mit
Notebooks beschäftigt und
ich hab's in nächster Zeit online vor
mich mit Notebooks da großartig zu beschäftigen,
sodass ich dir was sagen könnte.
Hab ich keinen Bedarf grad aktuell dran.
Was Lenovo
ist schwierig zu bekommen wegen dem
Rechtsstreit mit Nokia?
Was haben die denn schon wieder für komische
Stonks-Anwalt-Dinger
da untereinander zu klären?
Über was streiten die sich denn grade?
Lawsuit.
Was Lenovo hat verkauft?
Okay, guck mal was der Heise schreibt so.
Patentstreit mit Nokia.
Lenovo stoppt Verkauf in
Deutschland. Oh!
Keck, wait.
Lenovo fehlt
Lizenz zur Nutzung des Videokurses.
Ah,
Lizenzscheiße, Alter.
Wie mir diese ganze
Patent- und Lizenzierungsgeschichte
mega sowas von auf den
Sack geht, merke ich jetzt
hier einfach mal wieder dran.
Die Welt könnte
deutlich einfacher sein
ohne diesen Scheiß.
Und ich sag nicht, dass Leute, die
sich was ausdenken, kein Geld damit
verdienen sollen oder so.
Aber das ist unnötig kompliziert
und kacke einfach nur.
Guckt euch diesen Wirrwarr um Strikes
auf Twitch jetzt an.
Ich mein, klar, es soll nicht so sein,
dass jetzt irgendwelche Künstler am Hungerbrot
da irgendwie oder am Hungertuch
nagen müssen
und auf Twitch gucken sich alle
kostenlos ihr Zeug an. So ist das ja nicht
gedacht. Aber da wird ja teilweise
vom Rechteverwerter die
abgetretenen Rechte verwertet
von dem Urenkel, der das Rechteverwerter
seiner Mutter, so.
Also, das ist echter Wahnsinn,
was da läuft. Und am Ende kommt
ja noch nicht bei dem was an,
großartig, der es erstellt hat.
Übrigens, wisst ihr,
was ich mich schon seit einer Weile frage?
Warum darf
man eigentlich, und das ist jetzt eine wirklich ernst
gemeinte Frage, warum
darf man nicht
öffentlich-rechtliches
Fernsehprogramm frei verwenden?
Ich mein die Frage
wirklich ernst, weil, ich mein,
die Dinge heißen nicht umsonst öffentlich-rechtlich
und jeder von uns
bezahlt Gebühren dafür.
Ich mein, mir ist klar, warum das
rechtlich problematisch ist, ne?
Zig Leute haben irgendwelche Urheberrechtsansprüche
und die Typen wollen das nicht rausrücken.
Aber rein vom, vom
wie soll man das jetzt nennen, so vom
von den Ansichten her,
warum ist das
eigentlich nicht besser
geregelt? Ich mein, warum
ist öffentlich-rechtlicher Kram
nicht zur freien Verwertung
hergegeben?
Ja, ich mein jetzt nicht, wenn die
lizenzierten Filme ausstrahlen, ich mein die öffentlich-rechtlichen
Produktionen, ja? Also sprich,
warum kann ich nicht
oder warum darf ich nicht
ähm, das
verwenden für beispielsweise irgendwie
YouTube-Videos, die sich mit dem
Thema auseinandersetzen?
Ja, ich weiß, dass es urheberrechtlich geschützt ist,
aber es gibt regelmäßig
äh,
Klagen von, äh,
Ländern
gegenüber, äh,
äh, sagen wir mal Organisationen, Einzelpersonen,
Firmen, was auch immer,
die, äh, Beiträge verwendet haben
von ihnen, um sich mit
dem Inhalt auseinanderzusetzen.
Also zum Beispiel, man nimmt
nen, nen 40-Sekunden-Ausschnitt
von ner Talkshow, wo der Pfeiffer sich mal wieder
über Killerspiele auslässt
und berichtet da drüber was. Also sprich, man
zeigt das, zeigt das Video
und labert dann drüber.
Warum kann man
was überhaupt irgendwie
ein öffentlich-rechtlicher Sender was machen?
Das, äh, ich find, es liegt, es liegt doch schon
im Namen drinne, wenn das ein öffentlich-rechtlicher
Sender ist, den wir alle
bezahlen, warum kann man den
Content nicht frei verfügbar machen?
Das leuchtet mir net ein.
Wie gesagt, ich weiß, dass das rechtliche, äh,
Rahmenbedingungen aktuell
eben hergeben, dass das nicht frei ist.
Aber warum, warum nicht?
Ja, also, äh,
das leuchtet mir nicht ein. Ja gut, äh,
über kommerzielle Nutzung kann man sich jetzt
natürlich streiten.
Das ist ja dann wieder was anderes.
Aber die sind da, äh,
teilweise echt, äh, giftig,
was das angeht, ja.
Ist mir grad zu, ist mir grad zu den Kopf
geholt, also frag ich mich, frag ich mich schon ne Weile.
Warum, und ich denk, das ist
auch was, wo man sich, was man sich echt mal fragen kann,
warum ist das überhaupt, äh,
so, dass ich das bezahlen muss,
aber nicht verwenden darf?
Oder warum muss, müssen wir das
bezahlen und wir dürfen das nicht verwenden oder verwerten
für andere Sachen?
Das Beste ist immer noch, dass die öffentlich,
öffentlichen Reaction-Content wechseln.
Ja, genau, sowas mein ich.
Warum? Ich mein, guck mal,
jeder von uns bezahlt den Kram,
mehr oder weniger.
Warum darf ich nicht nen Reaction
drauf machen auf irgendwie nen, nen Beitrag,
sagen wir aus, was gibt's denn da, so, Wieso?
Oder so, ja, mal angenommen, mal angenommen,
es gibt mal wieder irgend so'n komischen Beitrag bei Wieso,
wo irgendwelche,
also ich, wir testen die besten Cloud-Anbieter.
Warum darf ich nicht
...
den Beitrag zeigen
und drauf reacten, um mich drüber auszulassen,
was die für'n Mist erzählen? Warum?
Das ist doch eigentlich auch
in so'n öffentlichen Interesse irgendwie dann.
Ja, also, es, die,
die Regelung, was die, was diese
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunksache angeht,
hups, die kann ich hier zum größten Teil
nicht nachvollziehen.
Ja, es ist aber ein komplett, komplett
eigenes Thema wieder. Ich bin da auch
...
so'n bisschen hin und her gerissen, ob ich das gut oder schlecht finde.
Diese, diese, diese,
dieser Zwang, dass
alles und jeder
unabhängig davon, ob er's
benutzt oder irgendwie sonst was,
das bezahlen muss, find ich prinzipiell schlecht.
Es gibt Leute,
die gucken das oft,
die konsumieren das, und die haben damit überhaupt kein Problem,
das, äh, sich da
zu Gemüde zu führen. Ähm,
wenn ich dann sehe, dass in solchen Zeiten wie jetzt,
wo die Leute teilweise Probleme haben, der Rundfunkbeitrag
angehoben wird, oder zumindest vorhatten,
den Rundfunkbeitrag anzuheben,
ähm, wenn du siehst, dass
dort
alleinerziehende Mütter, müsst ihr euch mal,
müsst ihr mal Google gucken, äh,
in, in, wie nennt man das, Beugehaft
genommen werden oder werden sollen, und ich glaube
wurden schon, weil sie den Rundfunkbeitrag
nicht bezahlt haben, also dann läuft
wirklich irgendwas aus dem Ruder.
Das ist nicht, das ist nicht normal, ja.
Dazu kommt, und das ist eigentlich
der größte Kritikpunkt, den ich
an diesem öffentlich-rechtlichen, äh,
Zwangsabgaben-Ding habe,
dass mir der Kontext
nicht gefällt.
Der Content gefällt mir zum größten Teil nicht,
weil ich den Eindruck habe, dass
gerade dort, wo es drauf ankommt,
nämlich, sei es jetzt irgendwelche
Berichterstattungen zu aktuellen Ereignissen,
dass das wirklich alles
andere als neutral passiert.
Ich habe mir zum Beispiel, als in den USA gewählt
wurde, ein bisschen, morgens habe ich
im Bett gelegen, habe ich ein bisschen im Smartphone rumgeguckt,
ja, da waren sie ja alle on,
ja, von ARD war on,
bis Spiegel, bis die Bildwand waren
alle on. So, und ich habe mal
ein bisschen geguckt, bei was war das, glaube ich,
äh, ich glaube, das war bei der Bild, habe ich
beeingeschaltet, ähm, mal
bei, was war das, Spiegel
TV oder so, und auch
mal bei der ARD oder Tagesschau.
Und ganz im Ernst,
die, man kann, man kann von den
Kandidaten halten, was man will.
Also, es soll auch ruhig jeder
wählen, was er will, ja, weil ja
vielleicht konnte ja einer von euch da mitwählen.
Aber,
ich habe den ARD-Stream aufgemacht,
ja, und das erste,
was ich gehört habe, war sinngemäß,
wo sie erzählt haben, wie dumm
ein Großteil der Amis ist, jetzt nicht
wortwörtlich, aber sinngemäß, und das wollten die auch
so sagen, wie dumm ein Großteil der Amis
ist, weil sie ja Trump gewählt haben, und die ARD
weiß es mal wieder besser.
The fuck, ist das neutrale Berichterstattung?
Wundere mich
davon, ob ich das jetzt mein Kandidat ist,
oder nicht, aber gerade als
öffentlich-rechtlicher Sender solltest du
die Sache doch möglichst
objektiv und neutral berichten.
Ich meine, die BILD hat das besser gemacht.
Und der BILD, also,
wem traust du das eher zu?
Der Sendung von der ARD oder
der BILD? Ich habe danach den BILD-Stream
angemacht, und da hatten die irgendwelche Typen
dort in Washington sitzen,
von der einen Seite, von der anderen Seite
haben sich darüber unterhalten, was denn so in den letzten Jahren
fehlgeschlagen, fehlgefeldet
wurde und sonst was.
Also, ähm,
die fucking BILD war
viel neutraler als das
in der ARD. Ich meine, das war jetzt so eine
Momentssache. Ich habe das nicht lange geguckt, ich habe das
eine Viertelstunde oder so vielleicht geguckt bei meinen.
Aber trotzdem, mir ist bei der ARD
direkt von Anfang
an so diese
diese Belehrungssache,
wir erklären euch jetzt,
wie das Ganze auszugehen hat
und wer unserer Meinung nach
der Richtige ist so. Ist sofort so
mitgeschwungen. Und die anderen,
die haben da einfach nur normal drüber geredet.
Was mir persönlich viel besser gefällt,
und gerade
die Aufgaben aus meiner Sicht von einem öffentlichen
und rechtlichen Sender wären.
Äh, doch Imp, du kannst Ausschnitte zeigen,
klar.
Du musst aber damit rechnen, dass
das dann der, also,
es gibt mit Sicherheit ein Gesetz, was
das abdeckt. Ja, es gibt ja auch genug
Entscheidungen für, wenn du was zeigst und dann
drüber redest, also
drüber laberst und dich mit dem Thema beschäftigst,
dann ist das erlaubt.
Was sich aber nicht, was aber
die Fernsehanstalt nicht davon
abhält, dich einfach mal
zu striken und anzuschauen,
nein, anzuzeigen ist es ja nicht, also quasi
dir unter, wie heißt das, Abmahnung
zu schicken, ähm, wo du
dann mit denen vor Gericht landest.
Was übrigens, lustigerweise,
wir auch mitbezahlen.
Das ist ja auch so ein Ding, was irgendwie schon
unter aller Sau ist, ne. Also sprich,
wenn
du, also, ich sag jetzt einfach mal, du, ihr,
wir bezahlen den Beitrag, wenn
wir dann damit, sagen wir mal, ein Reaction-Video
machen, was denen nicht gefällt,
dann verklagen
sie uns und wir müssen so, quasi,
bezahlen, dass sie uns, also, ich bezahle
die Klage gegen mich, quasi.
Fuck.
Ja.
Dann hab ich letztens einen Bericht drüber
gesehen, dass, äh,
irgendein Radiosender,
äh, irgendein
Radiosender hat ne,
äh, Youtube,
Youtube, äh,
Redaktion, sag ich jetzt, weiß nicht, wie man's
nennen mag, Channel,
äh, verklagt,
weil die nen,
äh,
Auszug von nem Beitrag von denen verwendet haben, was sie nicht gut
waren, ein bisschen da drüber hergezogen haben,
und die sind jetzt, das ist quasi nen,
ich weiß nicht, ob es richtig zusammen geht, das ist irgendwie nen Hamburger
Fernsehsender gewesen oder irgendwas
komplett am anderen Ende, die haben
sich jetzt ne Berliner, äh,
Edelanwaltskanzlei genommen, um
sie vor Gericht zu vertreten.
Was wir quasi auch mitbezahlen,
weil das ja öffentlich-rechtliche Gebühren sind.
Excellent. Ganz ex, ex, extrem
excellent, ja. Also gut, ich
mein, kannst das Geld natürlich rausgeben, weil,
du musst es ja nicht selbst verdienen. Und dazu kommt
auch ne Sache, die mir beim öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunk, äh, Geschichten ein bisschen auf den Keks geht.
Vieles der Gebühren,
oder Großteil der Gebühren, die man bezahlt,
werden ja nicht
etwa für, äh, Content,
den man sehen will oder nicht sehen
will, also nicht für Inhalte Content
verwendet, sondern zum Beispiel um die
Renten zu bezahlen der ARD-Leute
und ZDF-Leute, also da ist auch
ein hoher Anteil
Altersvorsorge drin, also sprich, selbst
wenn die nichts machen,
die müssen quasi den Rundfunkbeitrag erhöhen,
dass sie die Rente bezahlen können über kurz
oder lang. Also, das
System ist nicht so optimal,
finde ich. Verbesserungswürdig, ja.
Oder wie man so schön sagt, äh,
im Business, dort gibt es noch
Sachen nachzuschärfen.
Auch so ne schöne Umschreibung von, das ist scheiße, ne?
Nachschärfen.
Äh...
Schau dir diverse Streams von
Charmsupportern-Demos an, überdenk nochmal dein
Thema. Da ist kaum einer dabei gewesen, der nicht
eine... Das ist doch egal.
Das ist doch, das ist doch
vollkommen egal.
Das können beides meinetwegen die größten
Volldeppen aller Zeiten sein.
Aber es kann nicht sein,
dass dir die ARD oder ein Sender
quasi mit jedem Satz
unterschwellig mitteilen
möchte, was die korrekte Ansicht ist.
Du kannst dir die Meinung ja selber bilden.
Guck dir die Demos an und sag, die sind alle
bescheuert, das ist gut, du hast dich mit dem Thema
beschäftigt, aber es soll dir keiner
vorkauen,
was jetzt deine
Weltansicht sein soll.
Das sind die meiner Meinung nach überhaupt
nicht für da. Machen sie aber.
Genauso, auch so ein Ding,
ich hab nen Auszug
gesehen, wo sie berichtet haben über diese
nicht die letzte
Corona-Demo,
die vorletzte Corona-Demo,
da wo irgendwelche Leute die Treppe
vom Reichstag hochgerannt sind und sowas.
Ja, hab ich gesehen bei der ARD
und das
wurde so dargestellt, als waren
das irgendwie, frag mich wie viel waren es denn, 40.000
oder so, 40.000
entweder Verrückte oder Nazis.
Wo ich mir auch gedacht hab, alter,
wie großartig undifferenziert
kannst du das ja nun wirklich nicht machen.
Da sind mit Sicherheit
viele Idioten dabei,
da sind halt vielleicht irgendwelche Kerle noch
am Start, wie hier
der vegane Koch oder
Xavier Naidoo, der ja sagt, es gibt nicht mal Viren
oder sowas, da sind mit Sicherheit Leute dabei,
die richtig Dachschaden haben.
Aber, du kannst dich nicht pauschal
hinstellen, btw. die bezahlen die Gebühren
da auch für, du kannst dich nicht hinstellen
und solche Sachen da
den Leuten mit auf den Weg geben, die das gucken,
da sind mit Sicherheit
auch
genug Leute dabei,
die einfach nur wahnsinnig unzufrieden sind mit der aktuellen
Situation, weder leugnen,
dass es Corona gibt, weder leugnen, dass es
Viren gibt, weder Nazis sind,
noch Reichsbürger sind, noch sonst was,
sondern einfach nur Leute, die die aktuelle
Situation aus unterschiedlichsten Gründen
scheiße finden. Und da kannst du dich
nicht hinstellen und so tun, als sind das
alles irgendwelche Verrückte und Nazis.
Das wird der Situation einfach nicht gerecht.
Das ist so ein Ding, das erwarte ich nicht von der ARD,
dass man das macht.
Leider ist es so.
Das sollte nicht so sein.
Das stimmt, also
es gab
sau viel Corona-Berichterstattung,
aber das ist ja
gerade in der aktuellen Situation
ist ja auch okay, irgendwie.
Also das Corona-News finde ich okay.
Ob man da jetzt jeden Tag
irgendwie
großartig
Brennpunkte
und Updates braucht,
wage ich auch mal zu bezweifeln, weil ich meine im Prinzip
ändert sich ja da nicht täglich
irgendwas dran. Das ist ja weder heute auf einmal da
und morgen auf einmal weg.
Ne, ich folge auf Twitter gar keinen, weil auf Twitter
sind zum größten Teil nur Leute, die mir auf den Sack
gehen. Aber was mich halt einfach nur
wundert ist, warum kriegt das
die BILD sogar
besser hin?
Das ist ja eigentlich das, was mich schockiert hat dabei.
Von der BILD erwarte ich das nun wirklich
nicht. Von der BILD hätte ich
erwartet, dass die übelst pro der einen Seite
und pro der anderen Seite berichten.
Nichtsdestotrotz ist es egal, ob man es gut oder schlecht findet,
bezahlen muss man es eh.
Drum rum kommt man da nicht.
Ja gut. So, wo sind wir
stehen geblieben? Was haben wir da? 21 oder 20?
So spät.
So, ich wollte noch gucken.
Was ich hier noch...
Ach du Scheiße, das ist ja noch...
Ich hab erst drei Zeilen oder so von meiner Einkaufsliste
runter. Ja genau, was ich mir auch noch
bestellen wollte, was übrigens exzellentes
exzellentes Equipment ist.
Ich wollte mir nämlich noch
ein paar Shellys mit Power Meter
bestellen. Die da.
Was du zahlst seit Umzug
keine Rundfunkgebühr. Das ist natürlich auch gut.
Da haben sie es wahrscheinlich noch nicht gecheckt.
So, ähm...
Genau. Was an den Dingern wirklich gut
ist, also
außer, dass sie so groß sind wie zwei Oreo
Kekse aufeinander.
Das, ich versuch grad mal, ob die irgendwo einen Anschlussplan
haben. Das sind
Relays, die ich
über das WLAN schalten kann. Um jetzt mal wieder
von so der aktuellen Diskussion hier weg zu kommen.
Das sind Relays, die ich über das WLAN schalten kann.
Und zwar
mit
Firmware, die keine Cloud braucht.
Obwohl das Shelly Cloud heißt.
Ich sagte es ja jedes Mal, das ist total hängengeblieben.
Dass man
shelly.cloud als Domain hat
und eines der hauptsächlichen Verkaufsgründe
ist, dass man es nicht über die Cloud
verwendet. Also es ist wirklich massive
Big Brain Idee.
Also ich muss in den Shop, sind da Anschlusspläne?
Genau.
Weil
ich hab ein paar, also zum Beispiel
ist eine Sache, die ich gerade im Kopf habe, warum ich mir
zumindest mal einen bestellen will. Und ihr wisst ja,
ich bestelle immer mindestens drei.
Wenn ich sowas bestelle.
Im Flur haben wir eine Steckdose,
da wird immer ein Staubsauger dran geladen.
So ein Akku.
Akku Staubsauger.
Und das Problem
ist,
dass der beim
Aufladen, also normalerweise
sollte er, wenn er aufgeladen ist, geht die LED
aus und gut ist.
Und das Netzteil wird
auch ein bisschen warm.
Was dabei ist.
Und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, es wäre erstens cool,
wenn ich das ausschalten könnte, wenn ich es über Nacht
lade, abends aus dem Bett.
Weil ich nicht will, dass
das Netzteil vielleicht doch mal anfängt zu fackeln.
Ich könnte einfach ein anderes Netzteil kaufen.
Aber was viel cooler ist, dadurch,
dass die quasi gucken, was
das ganze Zeug verbraucht, was
da dran hängt,
kann ich daraus mir ableiten,
ob der Staubsauger vollgeladen
ist oder nicht.
Wäre lustig, wie du gefühlt jeden Stream
die Shellys zeigst. Ja, die Dinger sind auch Poggers.
Also sprich, ich kann dann einfach
überwachen, wie viel
das Ladegerät so verbraucht,
bzw. wie viel
Watt das gerade lädt,
der Staubsauger.
Und wenn Akkus geladen werden, das ist ja immer so
eine Kurve. Also sprich, das geht dann
erstmal volle Pulle los,
mit so und so viel
und dann geht es am Ende wieder runter.
Die letzten 20% von so einem Akku
lädst du ja nicht
genauso volle Pulle
wie die ersten 2 Drittel
von dem Akku.
Das ist aber ein bisschen weniger.
Und deswegen,
ich habe mir das mal angeguckt,
wenn der so,
ich weiß es jetzt aus dem Kopf gar nicht mehr,
ich glaube unter 4 Watt
Verbrauch fällt, dann ist er eigentlich
voll.
Man würde ja eigentlich davon ausgehen, er geht aus.
Aber es könnte auch sein, dass
der aus ist und irgendwelche Standby-Dinger
einfach nur so viel brauchen.
Man würde ja davon ausgehen,
der schaltet das einfach ab.
Die Ladeschaltung am Akku macht das einfach dicht.
Vielleicht ist einfach nur
die 4 Watt,
die Wärme vom Netzteil
und die LED oder was auch immer.
Keine Ahnung. Zumindest, wenn das
unter 4 Watt Verbrauch hat, habe ich schon nachgeguckt,
dann ist der Staubsauger voll.
Und
deswegen wollte ich mir so ein Ding
unten an die Steckdose basteln,
hinter die Steckdose basteln.
Da kann man einmal vom Tablet an- und ausschalten
und ich bekomme mit, weil der Staubsauger voll ist.
Was eigentlich eine ziemlich nice Anwendung ist.
Was ist was?
Zu deiner Info wurde gestern
ein Querdenken-Anhänger
und auch ein Anmelder
einer Demo festgenommen,
der auf Facebook ein Video gepostet hat,
dass er heute am Freitag in die Schule gehen wird.
Was die Kinder zu...
Ach du Scheiße.
Es gibt schon genug Leute mit Dachschaden.
Metzger von Beruf.
Okay,
da würde ich mir jetzt Gedanken machen.
Kommt er mit dem Küchenbeil oder wie?
Tja, wie gesagt, ich will nicht
bestreiten, dass es da total bescheuerte
Leute gibt, ja.
Ist mit Sicherheit so.
Aber davon auszugehen, dass es bei 40.000 Leute
nur bescheuerte
sein müssen, das ist ein bisschen zu einfach.
Genau, davon bestelle
ich mir nochmal drei Stück.
Und wo wir gerade dabei sind...
Warum ist der auf
der Seite so teuer, der 1PM?
Das ist eigentlich eine gute Frage.
Bei Amazon ist der billiger, oder?
Ist der eigentlich irgendwie nur 2,20?
Ja, WTF?
Warum?
Hä?
Warum ist der so teuer?
Warum kriege ich den bei Amazon für 20
und im offiziellen Shop für 37?
Nein, nein, einer kostet 37.
Ne, dass ich...
Achso.
Oh.
Okay, das habe ich verkackt.
Okay, gut.
Der kostet weniger, alles klar.
Ich habe nichts gesagt.
Wie weit bist du mit deinem RTSP-Dings?
Also, ich habe heute eingebaut,
dass der
theoretisch die Streams aufnehmen
kann, wenn man einen Knopf drückt.
Warum diese Form? Passt der Unterputz?
Ja. Das Problem ist,
eigentlich, also,
um nochmal was zu diesem Kamera-Aufnehmen-Projekt
zu sagen hier, also,
wer wissen will, von was ich meine,
ich habe es ja sogar mal nach einem Stream auf GitHub
hochgeladen,
das ist übrigens Fake mit den 95%
JavaScript, das sind eher
80% C Sharp, der Rest JavaScript, das ist
den 95% JavaScript, weil ich hier
komplette, komplettes
View.js eingecheckt
habe.
Kannst du vergessen.
Genau, was wollte ich jetzt sagen
bei dem Projekt?
Ich tue mir immer schwer,
motiviert zu bleiben, wenn sich so ein Projekt
mal 3, 4, 5
Wochen hinzieht und
man nicht
so richtig vorwärts kommt, das ist auch ein bisschen was
komplizierteres.
Und das Problem, was ich auch noch habe, ist, ich
bin halt kein wirklich
guter
JavaScript Frontend
Design Mensch, ja.
Also, ich kriege da was
halbwegs Ansehnliches hin,
aber ich tue mir da teilweise schon echt schwer mit.
Und, ähm,
ich bin ja aktuell so am gucken,
ob ich nicht vielleicht da noch den einen
oder anderen dafür gewinnen
kann, der da mitmacht,
weil zu zweit, und das habe ich gesehen,
wo ich da mit meinem Kollegen mal diesen
Routenplaner programmiert habe zusammen,
ich habe mit einem Arbeitskolleg
zusammen einen Routenplaner programmiert,
wo sich Handwerker quasi
ihre Termine reinklicken können
und der berechne dann die
optimale Route von Kunde zu Kunde
und man kann auch Zeitslots eintragen, sprich
man muss um 12.30 Uhr bei dem sein
und um 14.30 Uhr bei dem und das berücksichtigt
er dann.
Das hat viel mehr Spaß gemacht, war viel
motivierender, weil wir das zu zweit gemacht haben.
Da kam auch was viel besseres raus.
Ja.
Wenn ich da alleine am Start bin,
da verliere ich immer so ein bisschen die Lust.
Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht kennt ihr das,
mir geht es immer so, am Anfang bin ich übelst
motiviert und denke mir 20.000 Sachen aus,
was man alles noch geiles einbauen könnte
und ich habe so
so einen Fehler,
den ich dann immer mache,
ich verliere mich da oftmals
in Detailimplementierung.
Ich bin dann zwei Stunden am überlegen,
ob ich jetzt
was weiß ich,
da einen Public Property auf die Klasse
oder doch lieber ein Event mache
oder ob ich nicht vielleicht doch lieber
Reactive Extensions noch mit reinnehmen soll
oder ob ich die Datenbank vielleicht
nicht lieber über CraftQL machen soll
oder sonst was. Da habe ich zwei Stunden
lang überlegt, habe zwar einiges
Neues gelernt, aber im Prinzip
nichts geschafft.
Okay, ich sehe der Chat kennt das.
Ich glaube das ist relativ normal.
GRPC wäre jetzt nochmal übertrieben.
Also GRPC machen wir tatsächlich
Kengi. GRPC machen wir
und zwar GRPC machen wir
für die
Object Detection.
Soll ich euch das, ich zeige euch das jetzt
mal kurz. Für alle, die
beim letzten Stream nicht dabei waren,
ich starte das jetzt mal, dass ihr wisst, wovon ich rede.
Ich mache mal Progras an
und dann zeige ich euch den letzten
Stand, den wir auch im Stream
hatten. So und
wir haben nämlich was programmiert, wo man
Webcams oder nicht, nicht Webcams,
Security Kameras
empfangen kann.
Und was ist das für ein Desktop?
Das ist der beste Desktop.
Das ist Supreme, Big Brain
Desktop.
So und wo man Webcam Streams
empfangen kann.
Jetzt kann ich mal kurz gucken, was wir machen müssen.
Wo ist FFmpeg?
Oh.
Oh, nein, mein Rider läuft ab. Geh sofort.
Watch run.
So.
Wow. Ah, da steht noch
das iPhone drin.
Lull. Ja, Moment, das muss raus.
Da steht noch das iPhone
drin. Ne, ne, das iPhone brauchen wir
nicht. Wir brauchen hier den Stream.
Nehmen wir hier mal rein.
So und jetzt kann ich euch zeigen, was das macht.
Machen wir mal Chrome auf.
Localhost 5000.
Oh.
What the f...
Fuck.
Ah, ja. What?
Warum? Was ist hier los?
Ah, die Object Detection läuft
nicht. Äh.
Object Detection läuft nicht.
So, jetzt aber.
Fünf Zuschauer,
ja, das ist normal.
Immer, sobald man irgendwie sowas in der Richtung
ist, ist es immer vorbei. So, dafür steigt's
jetzt wieder, wenn ich zeige, was im Browser rauskommt
am Ende. Genau. Also, wir haben nämlich
eine Web-Anwendung programmiert, die
Kamerabilder empfängt. Also, ich hab
so ein Video, so ein
YouTube-Video runtergeladen von einem Typ,
der irgendwelche Gymnastik-Übungen
macht.
Und ihr seht, der macht, ähm,
Object Detection.
Also, sprich, der erkennt, dass
das eine Person ist und wo die sich im Bild befindet.
Was eigentlich schon
ziemlich nice ist, ne?
Und das alles jetzt nicht mit allzu großer,
mit allzu großem Rechenaufwand. Ich mein,
guckt euch das mal an.
Das Ding braucht...
Ich mach das hier mal groß.
Äh.
Das Ding braucht grad 4%
CPU-Last. Okay, du, äh,
die Object Erkennung ist nicht mit dabei.
Die Object Erkennung braucht auch noch ein bisschen was.
Aber es ist nicht, es ist nicht so viel, ja?
Also, es ist, lass es mal
15, 10, 10, 15% sein. Also, sprich,
das läuft auch auf nem Raspberry Pi
halbwegs, so mit, so mit,
keine Ahnung,
1, 2 Bildern die Sekunde. Aber das reicht ja voll und ganz.
Genau, ähm,
das ist übrigens ein Cellphone, falls ihr's noch nicht
wusstet. Ja, aber das Ding ist auch
trainiert auf Personen. Deswegen funktioniert
das ganz gut. So, und das
ist das, was wir letztens im Stream programmiert haben.
Das ist das, wovon ich grad gesprochen hab mit,
dass ich bei solchen Projekten immer übelst unmotiviert
bin, wenn ich da alleine dran am Basteln
bin. Stimmt, wir hatten, wir hatten doch noch
das Video mit dem Fitness, mit dem Fitness-Grill.
Moment.
War, war Blubb das Fitness-Grill?
Äh, ist das das Fitness-Grill?
Das ist das Fitness-Grill,
genau. Das machen wir jetzt mal an.
Weil, man sieht auch in Bewegung,
dass der das ziemlich gut erkennt.
Muss das Video erstmal
anlaufen, klar. Also, das simuliert jetzt
Webcams. Guck mal, der erkennt ne Bank.
Der erkennt ne Person.
Und das alles relativ Echtzeit.
So, so ungefähr mit,
sagen wir mal, so zwei Sekunden.
Der nimmt jeden Keyframe,
der nimmt jeden Keyframe und schiebt
das durch diese Object Detection.
Das heißt, der erkennt hier halt auch,
dass die Person hin und her wackelt, ja.
Die macht jetzt gleich irgendwelche Liegestützen oder so
auf der Bank und dann seht ihr auch hier, zack, das geht
nach vorne. Wir haben uns extra
von YouTube Fitness-Videos runtergeladen, um das
auszuprobieren, weil in Fitness-Videos
bewegen sich in der Regel die Leute. Guck mal,
der erkennt sogar, dass die hoch und runter auf der Bank
geht. Excellent.
Übrigens, die Object Detection ist ganz schön am rödeln gerade.
Genau, und das ist das, was wir
letzten Stream gebastelt haben.
Worum es mir eben ging,
bei dem, was ich hier gezeigt
hab. Ja, und da hab ich halt immer das Problem,
dass ich mich, ähm,
und der Chat ja auch,
dass ich mich bei solchen
Projekten immer vom Hundertste ins Tausendste
am basteln bin, anstatt mich mal auf irgendwas zu konzentrieren.
Also, was ich heute gemacht hab, ist,
ich hab eingebaut, dass man die Sachen
aufnehmen kann von den Webcams. Also sprich,
man hat einen Aufnahme-Button, und
sprich, man kann Aufnahme auflösen durch
Object Detection, durch
manuelles Klicken auf einen Button, oder
durch einen Timer. So, das hab ich heute eingebaut.
Aber,
ich bin da, also, wenn man da mit mehreren
Leuten dran programmiert, ist deutlich motivierender,
als wenn man dann nur alleine
bastelt.
Wie viel Gigabyte RAM hast du?
Gute Frage, ich glaub 32G?
Ja, 32G.
Aber man braucht da nicht
viel RAM für.
Du brauchst, glaub ich, zum Trainieren relativ viel RAM.
Äh, wie zur Hölle
funktioniert so eine Erkennung? Gut,
wie das im Detail funktioniert, kann ich dir nicht
sagen, weil ich nehm ein fertiges, äh,
fertige, ich sag mal
Library, ist nicht wirklich ein Library, ich nehm was,
das ist nicht YOLO, nein, das ist nicht YOLO,
das ist TensorFlow Lite,
mit
irgendwelchem vortrainierten
Set mit,
frag mich nicht, ganz vielen Personen,
dass der gut Personen erkennt.
Das ist nicht YOLO.
YOLO hab ich mir auch überlegt, ob ich YOLO nehmen soll,
also YOLO ist auch ne, ne Object Detection,
du sagst, you only look once,
heißt das, glaub ich, in dem Fall,
aber YOLO ist, ähm,
unbenutzbar langsam aufm
Raspberry Pi.
YOLO ist genauer, ups,
das wollt ich grad aufmachen, äh,
YOLO ist genauer als diese TensorFlow
Geschichte,
die ich hier verwende,
aber,
das ist halt schneller, und ganz ehrlich,
wenn's da um
alle zwei Sekunden
mal nen Keyframe zu erkennen geht,
ist Genauigkeit jetzt nicht
so extrem
wichtig, es ist allemal besser
als Motion Erkennung von den normalen,
von den meisten anderen Kameras.
YOLO,
worum geht's grade? Äh, um,
um das hier.
Echtzeit Objekterkennung in Bildern.
YOLO.
Neun Monat, Dankeschön
für den Sub. Excellent Subscription.
Big Brain Sub.
Wäre damit sicher auch ne Fahrzeugerkennung
möglich, oder?
Ja, gibt's auch, gibt's auch, gibt's
genug, äh, Beispielprojekte,
wo das Leute schon umgesetzt haben, aber,
wenn man sowas machen möchte, wie Fahrzeugerkennung,
oder, äh,
Leute in der Fußgängerzone,
dann kann man das nicht
mit dem Raspberry Pi und diesem Projekt machen,
was ich gemacht hab. Das kann man mit diesem Projekt
vielleicht machen, dann braucht man, äh,
aber nen Hardwarebeschleuniger,
am besten ist ne ordentliche Rechner
mit Grafikkarte.
Dann kann man auch YOLO über GPU machen,
das ist, hat bessere Erkennung,
und geht mit der GPU
flitzt's schneller.
Also wenn man da wirklich Sachen machen will,
wie in Echtzeit, äh, Autos, äh,
Straßenverkehr analysieren, oder, äh,
Fußgängerzonen analysieren, das
geht, aber dann braucht man doch ne ganze
Ecke bessere Hardware.
Was aber dann auch kein Problem haben sollte,
äh, sein sollte, weil wenn man solche Anwendungszüge
hat, dann
kann man da ja auch die passende Hardware für, äh,
verwenden.
Genau, so, davon wollte ich mir drei Stück bestellen,
37 Euro, passt,
Poggers, next.
So, ähm,
wo war ich denn jetzt stehen geblieben?
Außer, dass es gleich 21 Uhr
45 ist.
Ähm, kennst du den Lebenslauf
von dem YOLO-Typ?
Äh, äh,
keine Ahnung, ähm,
was ich mir mal wieder bestellen wollte,
hier,
excellent, ähm,
ich hatte letztens mal,
Alter, was ist das für nen Preis mittlerweile?
Sind die noch ganz dicht?
Ich geb doch
keine 8 Euro für die,
für 300 Gramm aus, what the
fuck? Sag mal,
ist irgendwie alles, was ich, was ich gerne, gerne
bestelle und, und esse,
irgendwie in den letzten zwei Monaten
dreimal teurer geworden?
8 Euro für 300 Gramm?
China-Kohl!
Kimchi gibt's auch
im Supermarkt, ja, aber es schmeckt nicht jedes.
Also, das
schmeckt mir am besten. Das ist sogar das
einzige, das einzige
vegane
Produkt, was ich
kaufe. Wobei man auch hot,
hot, Kimchi hot kaufen kann.
Aber was ist mit denen los, Alter?
7,50 pro Dose,
7,50, für 7,50 pro Dose
kriegst du wahrscheinlich schon, hab ich nicht,
Erdöl oder, oder,
ja, Gold nicht, aber
andere Sachen als Kimchi.
Letztendlich ist das eingelegter China-Kohl,
was rechtfertigt,
dass das 7,50 Euro kostet.
Die anderen Sachen bewegen
sich in besseren Regionen.
Außer das da vielleicht.
Alter, warum ist das so teuer,
das andere Zeug?
Man überlegt,
dass noch andere, andere viele
mögen, was?
Man überlegt, ob das noch andere,
ah, du meinst, ob das vielleicht noch so viele
andere mögen, dass es grad knapp ist
oder so.
Aber das ist, ich mein, das ist eingelegter China-Kohl,
den kauf ich nicht für 8 Euro, 7,50 Euro.
Also, ähm,
sowas hier in dieser Richtung gibt's, gibt's glaube ich
auch beim Edeka und sowas schmeckt kacke.
Das schmeckt,
also, ich hab mal beim Edeka
so eine kleine Dose Kimchi
gekauft und das hat, das hat im Prinzip
geschmeckt wie Gewürzgurken
China-Kohl.
So, so wie als hätte man China-Kohl
in Gewürzgurken-Zeug eingelegt.
Richtig kacke.
Aber das hier ist nice.
Das ist richtig gut.
Das ist, das ist scharf.
Hot ist, geh ich mal von aus,
hot hatte ich noch nicht, ich hab bisher tatsächlich,
wie gesagt, das ist das einzige vegane, was ich, was ich
je bestellt hab, ja.
Hot ist wahrscheinlich ordentlich
hot, weil, weil das ist auch,
das hat auch schon eine gewisse Schärfe,
aber hot ist wahrscheinlich richtig power.
Das schmeckt richtig gut.
Wenn man so saures Zeug
mag, ja. Also es ist, es ist
ziemlich, ziemlich sauer.
Was ist bisher im Warenkorb? Ja, heute
bei Amazon nicht, nicht allzu viel.
Eine SD-Karte, einen Kartenleser
fürs iPad und ein paar Zigbee-Schalter.
Ich wurde
heute ein wenig, ein wenig sidetracked
zwischendurch, ja.
Bisschen öfters.
Genau, ja gut, aber ich, ich
wollte wieder eine Dose Kimchi kaufen, was ist hier los?
Warum, warum, warum
geht das heute nicht?
Weil ich geb keine 57
aus, kannst du knicken.
Man muss aber halt auch sagen, weil ich grad gemeint hab,
das ist das einzige vegane, was ich kauf, ähm,
man kann Kimchi bestimmt auch super vegan machen,
ne, das ist im Endeffekt China-Kohl,
Chili-Paste
und das halt stehen lassen.
Luftig
verpackt stehen lassen. Mit, mit
Zusatzdingern, ja.
Gut, manche machen dann wahrscheinlich noch irgendwie
bisschen Fisch-Zeugs
mit rein oder so, das ist wahrscheinlich dann die
nicht-vegane Variante.
Aber so viel Geld geb ich nicht aus.
Fuck.
Vergiss, so viel Geld geb ich nicht aus.
Ne, ne.
So, da wollte ich bei der Gelegenheit grad nochmal gucken,
ob's meine Zigbee-Thermostate
ein bisschen günstiger gibt
und vielleicht auch in einem, in einem, äh,
bei einem Shop, wo ich was
bestellen kann. Nein, gibt's nicht.
Die wollen ja eh...
Sag mal, wird alles, was ich
kauf, irgendwie wirklich jetzt zwei Monate später
teurer? Ich hab das auch noch für, frag mich nicht,
20 Euro oder so gekauft.
Was ist da los? Bei Pearl bestell
ich nix, aus Prinzip. Den Laden
mag ich nicht. Der sieht aus wie
ein schlechter Shop von 1995.
Ich hab da noch nie was bestellt
und ich werd da auch nix bestellen.
Ich, ich kann euch gar nicht genau sagen,
warum. Aber dieser
Shop, gegen den hab ich irgendwie ultra Abneigung.
Vielleicht versteht's
jemand, wahrscheinlich nicht. Ich kann's
nicht genau erklären, aber die Optik
schreckt mich unglaublich ab. Ich will da nix bestellen.
Find ich auch, das sieht aus
wie ne schlechte, wie ne schlechte Webseite
von 1998.
Vielleicht nicht ganz so schlimm, aber
in die Richtung auf jeden Fall.
Zigbee, Zigbee ist ein, äh,
ein, äh, wireless
Protokoll
für IoT-Geräte.
Sieht aus wie Teleshopping, genau.
Wahrscheinlich find ich's deswegen nicht so schlecht,
weil es aussieht wie Teleshopping.
Ich hab diese Tele, ich hab das gehasst
früher im Fernsehen, diese Teleshopping-Dinger.
Oh mein Gott, oh mein Gott,
Bob, es ist so toll!
Was man damit alles machen kann!
Und jetzt gibt es sogar zwei für den Preis von...
Oh mein Gott, Bob, ist das toll!
Nee, nee, nee, das war...
Das konnt ich mir immer nicht angucken, das war ganz grausam.
Hab heute entdeckt, dass man bei
Nord Sea Infinite gratis
Backfischbrötchen bekommen kann.
Warum geben die einem gratis
Brötchen so viel man will?
Genau, also Zigbee ist ein
WLAN, äh, ein wireless, nicht WLAN,
wohlgemerkt, kein WiFi,
aber ein drahtloses Protokoll
für, äh, zum Beispiel
Heimatomatisierungsgeräte.
Der Vorteil davon ist,
es braucht
weniger Strom als WLAN.
Also Zigbee-Geräte
oder Seawave-Geräte halten in der Regel
batteriemäßig
viel länger als
WLAN-Geräte.
Der Name ist vielleicht ein bisschen doof.
Ja, aber es gibt so
zwei Sachen, es gibt Zigbee und es gibt Seawave.
Nimmt sich alles nix,
rein von technischer Sicht ist beides
okay, funktioniert beides gut,
ähm, Seawave
hat eigentlich den großen Vorteil,
dass die Geräte
per Standard
untereinander kompatibel sind,
was erstmal gut klingt.
Problem ist aber, Seawave-Geräte
sind meistens eine Ecke teurer
und
bei Zigbee sind viele
große Hersteller dabei,
die da mitmischen,
die zwar nicht wirklich drauf achten, großartig kompatibel
zu sein, aber es gibt
mittlerweile genug Drittanbieter-Software,
die ziemlich viele
Geräte ansprechen kann. Das heißt,
so der große Vorteil von Seawave ist
eigentlich auch weg und ich sehe
es so, dass
Zigbee gerade gewinnt,
was
IoT-Protokolle
angeht. Und ich meine nicht gegen
WLAN, gegen WLAN stinkt nix an.
WLAN ist das einzige, was
es in nächster Zeit
geben wird in der Richtung.
WLAN tut ja auch gut.
Was 5 Fischpunkte gleich
Bart... Moment, was?
50 Fischpunkte gleich gratis
Backfisch registrieren mit E-Mail gibt dir...
Moment!
10-Minute-Mail incoming.
Ah ne,
Nordsee
Fischpunkte.
Kundenclub-Prämien, das da?
Meinst du das? Das probieren wir
jetzt aus.
Das probieren wir jetzt aus.
Never donate and never sell.
Never accept neighbors Wi-Fi
free entertainment.
Das probieren wir jetzt aus.
Wo kann man sich da anmelden?
Sammle bei jedem deiner Nase...
Der App!
Alter, können die das nicht mal ordentlich machen?
Warum muss ich das über die Scheiß...
Apps! Warum?
Warum nicht einfach über den Rechner im Browser?
Muss das wirklich immer so ne...
Für alles irgendeine eigene App
installieren?
Wenn ich in den Laden gehe,
wenn ich in den Laden gehe und dort
mein QR-Code einscanne, dann ist es ja okay,
dass ich das mit einer App machen muss.
Aber muss ich das wirklich
von Anfang an in der App machen und kann das nicht
über den Browser machen?
Es ist Promo für die App. Ja, da hast du recht.
Ja und, wie ist das so?
Also hier, äh...
Maxxriss, wie ist das so?
Kann man da mit 10-Minute-Mail sich registrieren?
Weil dann installiere ich mir einfach die App
auf, ähm...
einem Android-Tablet.
Oder auf irgendeinem
ausgemusterten Android-Tablet
generiere ich mir ein paar Codes.
Weil den QR-Code, den brauche ich ja dann wahrscheinlich nicht
in der App.
Achso, doch, du brauchst den QR-Code in der Nordsee.
Das probier ich, das muss ich mir aufschreiben.
Das, das probier ich aus.
Dann geh ich, ich geh morgen zur Nordsee,
ich geh morgen, ich fahr morgen zur Nordsee
und hol mir 5 Brötchen.
Ey, das funktioniert, Alter!
Einfach nur um zu wissen, dass es funktioniert.
Exzellent, exzellent.
Hat sich wieder gelohnt zu streamen heute.
Jetzt müssen wir wieder morgen die Nordsee-Gemeiden.
Um was es geht?
Es geht um kostenlose Brötchen bei der Nordsee.
Okay, warte mal.
Nordsee-Club-App.
Ist mir doch egal, ob die Club-App schlechte
Bewertungen hat. Ich will kostenlose Brötchen haben.
Was interessiert mich schon, was für Bewertungen die App hat, Alter.
Was haben die sich eigentlich
dabei gedacht?
Dass der...
dass man ganz rechts an den Bildschirm muss,
um die Bilder durchzuscrollen.
Wer hat sich das bei...
Welcher Usability-Experte bei Google hat sich das eigentlich ausgedacht?
Nordsee-Club-Punkte.
Was?
Morses? Nein.
Wo steht denn da, was es da für Punkte gibt?
Mobile First.
Ja.
Jetzt der rote gibt es bestimmt auch für Windows.
Oh.
Naja, das werde ich aber auf jeden Fall morgen ausprobieren.
Kostenlose Nordsee-Brötchen.
Exquisite.
Was hältst du von der PS5?
Ich halte weder von PS5
noch von der Xbox
Series X
aktuell irgendwas,
weil ich keine Ahnung davon habe.
Ich habe mich damit
nur das Nötigste
mich darüber informiert.
Ich habe mir zweimal das Video angeguckt,
wo der eine Japaner
gesagt hat, dass die PlayStation 5
eine hat.
Aber ich kenne mich
nicht damit aus.
Ich weiß jetzt aus dem Stehgreifen
noch nicht mal genau,
was da jetzt für CPUs drin waren,
außer dass es irgendwelche AMD Dinger sind.
Ich glaube 8 Kerne oder 12.
8. Ich glaube 8.
Und SSDs haben sie.
Kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Das nächste, was ich machen werde,
ist in dieser Richtung.
Wenn denn dann
mal wieder RTX
8090 lieferbar sind,
so wie jetzt.
Und wenn
Ryzen
5900 lieferbar sind,
so anscheinend wie jetzt.
Hmmm.
Geil Max Riss.
Es ist Poggers, dass das funktioniert.
Ah, guck mal,
hier gibt es die Prämien.
Wundern die sich nicht,
wenn ich da mit 5 QR Codes
bei der Nordsee anrücke?
Wundern die sich da nicht irgendwie?
Okay, was gibt es denn?
Für 30 Fischpunkte
gibt es ein 0,2
Cola.
Für 40 gibt es ein
Prima.
Und für 50 gibt es ein
Backfischbaguette.
Oh, da gibt es ja mehrere Sachen
für 50.
Okay, okay, also.
Dann probiere ich das mal
morgen aus.
Ich nehme, dass es nicht so
auffällig ist, nehme ich einfach mal 5 Tablets mit.
Wenn das klappt, Alter.
Ich habe,
also an Tablets und Smartphones
mangelt es ja nicht.
Ich packe dann einfach mal 5 Tablets morgen
bei der Nordsee aus.
Also was könnte man da schönes zusammenstellen?
Einmal Pommes frites, einmal Backfischbaguette
und einmal was zu trinken dabei.
Ist doch eigentlich ganz gut, oder?
Braucht man drei, braucht man drei,
dreimal App.
Die haben doch bestimmt in ihren AGBs
sowas drin stehen.
Dass man es nur einmal
einlösen kann
pro Besuch
oder irgendwas in der Richtung.
Ich bin kaputt, wenn das klappt.
Wo haben wir denn in Hanau
irgendwie Nordsee? Wo ist denn da?
Wo haben wir denn Nordsee hier?
Einmal pro Gerät.
Kein Problem, ich nehme ja, frag mich nicht,
5 Tablets mit.
Ich habe genug Tablets,
also an Geräten mangelt es nicht.
Und danach schmeiße
ich die App runter und registriere mich neu.
Okay, wo haben wir denn in Hanau
Nordsee?
Nordsee, Hanau, was?
Wie, nur da?
Hä? Nur da?
Was ist denn das?
Hanau im...
Ach, da ist der Saturn, okay.
Ach, jetzt weiß ich, wo das ist.
Genau, hier steht
dieser Joint.
Da ist so ein
da ist so ein komische
frag mich nicht so
irgendein
Denkmal drauf, sieht aus wie ein Joint.
So,
das ist, also
die Frage ist, also
die eigentliche Frage ist,
lohnt es sich nur um
Nordsee quasi um
was kostet das? Um 3 Euro
zu gebeten. Lohnt es sich
dafür in die Stadt zu fahren,
5 Tablets mitzuschleppen
oder 3?
3 Tablets reichen auch.
In Corona-Zeiten
und dort sich
Pommes frites, ein Backfisch,
Spaghetti und Cola zu holen.
Klingt solide für dich.
Ich mein,
Geräte
mangels
nicht.
Wobei, morgen Vormittag
geh ich erstmal ne Runde wandern.
Dann werd ich das nicht machen.
Sass-Rate auf dem Raspberry Pi
Okay, nee, wir gucken. Jetzt fangen wir jetzt nicht an.
Es ist ja fast 22 Uhr.
Oh, das ist auch
massive Big Brain hier.
Kollege hat eine eigene App geschrieben,
die die Burger King API anspricht.
Die Gutscheincodes laufen niemals ab
und man kann da fast alles,
die es jemals gab, abfragen
und die klappen auch.
Und wie löst man die Gutscheincodes ein?
In der App?
Oder wie geht das?
Ich hab die Burger King App noch nie verwendet.
Ja, dann muss ich da morgen zur Nordsee.
Excellent.
Ähh
Du hast
korrekt festgestellt.
So sieht's aus.
Undercover.
Also, wenn das nicht
gegen irgendwelche AGBs verstößt,
dann ist das den Verkäufern vollkommen
egal.
Stimmt, wie sieht's eigentlich bei Ubisoft aus?
Ist da irgendwas Neues?
Twitter, wir gucken.
Polizei-Einsatz
Twitter.
Bei sowas ist Twitter tatsächlich nicht verkehrt.
Äh, Latest.
Ähh
Ist da irgendwas Neues?
Ich trau mich immer nicht, Twitter
bei solchen Sachen durchzuscrollen,
weil da posten manche auch mal irgendwelche abartigen Sachen
zwischendurch.
No, that has been identified for now.
Okay.
Dann war's vielleicht doch
irgendeine Drohung mit irgendeinem
Sprengsatz oder so.
Sunkfuck. Alles klar.
Mal schauen, was da rauskommt.
Bin echt gespannt und ich hoffe nicht, dass denen irgendwas passiert.
Ja, die Sache ist nur da, wo ich morgen
wandern gehe, ist komplett andere Richtung als
da, wo die Nordsee ist.
Ach, QR-Code.
Das heißt, was macht man dann?
Wenn QR-Code
Screenshotten und dort
vorzeigen oder wie ist das?
Moment. Github.
Muss ich jetzt gucken.
Das gibt's bestimmt auch auf Github schon.
Burger King RP.
Wobei ich gar nicht,
wobei ich Burger King überhaupt nicht mehr mag.
Ich war Jahre nicht mehr bei McDonalds
oder Burger King.
Burger King RP.
Burger King makes
you fat RP.
A rapper around Burger King.
Unofficial
Burger King RP.
Klar.
Willst du abwarten, wie sich AMD mit den Grafikkarten
schlägt?
Ehrlich
gesagt nicht.
Ähm.
Ich will jetzt ehrlich gesagt eigentlich
mal endlich einen neuen Rechner kaufen.
Aha.
Aha. Ist das so.
3080Ti
kommt demnächst.
Haben die nicht erzählt, diesmal wird's keine 3080Ti
geben?
Alter Nvidia Cheap Aid.
Da wird's wieder
zig Resitas Videos geben auf Youtube.
Ähm. Wo sich die Leute
über Nvidia lustig machen.
Da gibt's ja jetzt schon tausende von. Guckt euch das an.
Mann. Tausende gibt's davon.
Beste.
Ich lese, ich lese mir gar nicht mehr die Texte durch.
Ich find's, ich find's einfach nur schon lustig,
wenn ich's überhaupt nur, es reicht, wenn ich's mir
einfach sehe.
Ich könnte,
ich könnte da fast schon mitsprechen, obwohl ich kein Wort
Spanisch kann.
Chancla oder sowas kommt jetzt gleich.
Chancla.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was der sagt.
Also, doch, ich weiß, ich kenn die
Original-Story, aber.
Resitas ist das.
Der Typ.
Das ist ein spanischer, äh,
Komiker.
Der sich irgendwas mit Resitas nennt.
Beste.
Ich könnt mir den Scheiß den ganzen
Tag angucken.
Also, wenn du schlecht
drauf bist,
wenn du schlecht drauf bist, einfach.
Es gibt, es gibt zwei Sachen, die man
machen kann.
Ähm.
Es gibt zwei Sachen, die man machen kann,
wenn man schlecht drauf ist.
Einmal, man guckt sich fünf, fünf
Resita-Memes in Folge an.
Egal, um was es geht. Einfach zuhören, das ist gut.
Da ist man danach meistens schon besser drauf.
Oder, wenn man, wenn man
was anderes braucht. Wenn das nicht reißt,
äh, wenn's das,
wenn's das nicht reißt, dann hört
man sich einmal an, ähm,
dann hört man sich einmal den hier an.
Bester.
A huge success.
It's hard to overstate my satisfaction.
It's hard to overstate my satisfaction
Danach bist du besser drauf.
A better chance,
because we can.
Four levels except the ones who are dead.
But there's no sense crying over every mistake.
You just keep on trying
Also es gibt, glaube ich,
keiner, der danach nicht besser drauf ist,
wenn er das gehört hat.
DMCA, ja, das ist Spielemusik,
das passt schon.
Monkatoss, ich glaube nicht, dass es dafür einen Toss gibt.
Und das ist seit 2007 auf YouTube.
Habt ihr ihn gesehen?
Seht ihr das Chat?
Habt ihr es gesehen?
Wer da? Hier.
Da ist er.
Wo ist mein passendes Emote?
Ich kann dieses Emote nie verwenden.
Ich muss es jetzt. Wo ist es? Wo habe ich es?
Hier, da ist er.
Ich habe ihn gespottet.
Der originale Gaben war das da.
Technical, sag ich gleich was zu.
Joke.
Fettchats.
So, und
was auch noch übertrieben nice ist,
was man sich auch noch
anhören kann,
wenn gar nichts man hilft und man schlecht drauf ist,
das ist
10 Stunden Kirby Gourmet Race.
Besser.
Excellent.
Genau. Also wenn man schlecht drauf ist,
ist das das Beste, was man machen kann.
So, jetzt mal, um auf die Frage einzugehen,
von
Ja, aber wahrscheinlich nicht.
Vom Portal Song oder von
Game Musik.
Um jetzt mal kurz noch mal auf die Frage einzugehen
von Tactical
STG.
Ich weiß, die Frage ist vielleicht gerade unpassend.
Jedoch wollte ich dich mal fragen,
ob du noch Battlefield oder Overwatch spielst.
Also Battlefield, die letzten zwei Battlefields
habe ich nicht großartig gespielt.
Ich hoffe ja immer noch drauf,
dass mal wieder ein ordentliches Battlefield kommt.
So, und Overwatch
kann ich mir auch nicht mehr geben.
Also Overwatch hatte von Anfang an Probleme,
in einigen Disziplinen,
die sie bis heute nicht auf die Reihe gekriegt haben.
Zum Beispiel, dass 2CP von Anfang an
absoluter Kackspielmodus war,
was Blizzard nicht interessiert, sondern weitere Maps
in dieser Richtung gebaut hat und die noch
schlechter waren als die Original-Maps.
Und sie haben
an wirklich allen
Stellen irgendwie gefailt bei Overwatch.
Sie haben mit ihrer komischen Overwatch-League was
aufgebaut, was total einseitig
von Blizzard abhängt und
es dementsprechend keinerlei Tier 3,
Tier 2,
anderen Tournaments oder irgendwas
gibt, was man auch nur ansatzweise
aktive E-Sports-Szene nennen kann.
Was auch der Grund ist,
dass im Prinzip die einzigen Nachwuchsspieler
für die OWL halt
irgendwo aus Korea kommen.
Bis auf ein paar Ausnahmen.
Aber es gibt ja keine
großartige Nachwuchsszene und auch
keine... Also guck mal, wenn heute
jemand sagt, er möchte E-Sports-Profi
werden, was sagen die dann?
Leute, was meint ihr? Was sagen
Leute, die sagen wir mal jetzt irgendwie, sind sie nicht so gut?
Irgendwie 17, 18 sind und
sagen, hey, sie wollen, keine Ahnung,
Karriere in E-Sport machen. Was spielen
die für ein Spiel?
Lass ich mir alles gefa... Also,
ich lass mir gefallen, wenn einer sagt, lol,
ja, Fortnite
meinetwegen.
Ich mein dann vielleicht nicht die knallharte
E-Sports-Nummer. Die hatten mal dieses
World-Tournament, aber danach
kam glaube ich nichts mehr. Aber zumindest mit
Fortnite-Content und Gedöns kann man als...
Wenn man Pro-Gamer so
definiert als jemand, der mit
Spielen seinen Lebensunterhalt verdient,
dann kann man auch durchaus
Fortnite nehmen. Dann muss es halt
Gamer plus Video-Content
oder so sein. Ja, passt,
leuchtet alles ein?
Lol, Fortnite passt.
Battlefield 5 garantiert nicht.
CS, lol, Valorant vielleicht, ja.
Ich wundere mich auch immer, wie viele Leute,
wie viele Leute... PUBG in
Korea vielleicht, ja.
Eventuell Dota würde ich sagen.
StarCraft außerhalb von
Korea nicht.
Eventuell, ey,
meinetwegen auch noch FIFA.
Vielleicht auch noch Hearthstone
oder sowas. Meinetwegen
lass ich mir auch noch gefallen. Aber niemand,
niemand sagt Overwatch.
Und das ist das, worauf ich raus will.
Keiner sagt
Overwatch. Was man
an den Zuschauersalen sieht,
was man an dem
generellen Berichterstattung sieht,
was man daran merkt, wie zurück
gefahren der Content ist,
was man an der, was man dem ganzen
Game einfach anmerkt. Und
Blizzard hat's
an so vielen Stellen verkackt. Ich war
übelster Overwatch-Fan und ich fand das Spiel
am Anfang so,
sowas von geil und ich hab mir gedacht, hey,
die müssen bloß noch an den richtigen
Schrauben ein bisschen drehen, ja.
Zum Beispiel, dass so ein Observer-Modus,
so ein Spectator-Modus, so ein,
ne, nicht Spectator, so ein Replay-Modus
und sowas, dass das
Jahre gebraucht hat bei Overwatch, bis das
gekommen ist. War schon mal der Witz.
Und solche Geschichten, also,
ich dachte mir von Anfang an, hey, die müssen an ein paar
Sachen drehen, aber was haben sie gemacht?
Sie haben, äh,
ihre Schwächen
weiter ausgebaut, sowas wie
2CP-Maps oder ihre Patches
einmal im halben Jahr, die nicht bedacht
gepatcht haben, sondern, ähm,
eine Sache
komplett useless gemacht
und dafür eine andere Sache OP, sodass
ich so geforscht, das Meta muss ich
jetzt ändern, das kann nicht sein, dass die Leute 6 Monate
das gleiche spielen, also machen wir einfach das,
was die Leute jetzt spielen, useless und dann machen wir was anderes
und dann spielen die Leute das.
Wenn man das so macht, dann muss man das ein paar, alle paar Wochen
machen. Mittlerweile geht's schneller, weiß ich.
Ähm,
hat nicht auch Amazon ihren Overwatch-
Konkurrenten eingestellt? Äh, warte mal,
was war denn nochmal dieses,
jaja, ich weiß, ne, Amazon hat gesagt,
sie fangen wieder von vorne an zu entwickeln, aber
das Spiel war auch mega beschissen, ey.
Das hab ich mal bei Seagull oder so im Stream gesehen, das
hat, ich hatte so keinen Bock, dieses
Overwatch, dieses Amazon Overwatch zu spielen.
Ähm,
nicht Paladins, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Das, wenn ihr den Titel hört, werdet ihr
feststellen, das habt ihr gar nicht gehört, wie
hieß das denn, ähm, Crucible!
Crucible, Crucible, genau.
Crucible,
das weiß ich, genau das.
Crucible.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das überhaupt noch irgendwo drinsteht.
Ach, ach, ist official
cancelled.
Okay, ich dachte,
die haben's, also das ist ja noch gar nicht lange her, wo die's
cancelled haben, verstehe.
Lustig.
Ja, und, äh, wie gesagt, also, Blizzard hat das,
hat, hat
nicht die Stärken von Overwatch, zumindest ist das meine
Ansicht, ne, es gibt bestimmt andere Leute, die das anders sehen,
die haben nicht ihre Stärken ausgebaut
in Overwatch, die haben nicht
die Sachen angepasst, wo ich, wo
zumindest ich gesagt hätte, okay, der hätte man,
die hätte man ausbauen oder, oder
verbessern müssen, dass das Spiel richtig gut wird.
Sie haben eher noch die Sachen,
die nicht so gut waren an Overwatch
ausgeweitet.
Zum Beispiel, dass auch ziemlich viele
Helden gekommen sind, die absolut,
ähm,
keine Mechanics hatten. Ich mein,
was haben die sich gedacht bei Brigitte?
Am Anfang
nen, nen Held zu machen, der nen
No-Aim, äh, äh,
Melee-Stun hat.
Was, wie, wie kommt
man auf so ne Idee? Das,
macht man das quasi,
wer hätte man so, so, so,
sowas in Richtung High-Skill-Gameplay,
sowas wie Tracer, Genji oder so eingebaut,
der dann als Ultimate nen
Stun macht und, okay,
meinetwegen, ja, ähm,
aber du kannst doch nicht
so, so ne Melee, äh, ich halte,
ich halte, äh, einen Mausbutton gedrückt
und dasche gegen den Gegner und da ist gestunt
einbauen. Also,
also, ich kann
euch ehrlich gesagt nicht, ich kann,
ich kann nicht logisch
nachvollziehbar, äh,
irgendwie verstehen, was Blizzard
gemacht hat bei Overwatch.
Das ist mir,
das einzige, was ich mir zusammenreimen kann,
ist, dass man
eventuell zu sehr
versucht hat,
auf dieser,
wir sind eigentlich ein Casual
Game, wo es
mehr oder weniger ums reine
Just-for-Fun-Spielen geht,
also, außer, dass sie eben
versucht haben, diese Schiene zu bedienen
und gleichzeitig
versucht haben, ein auf
Hardcore-E-Sport-Game zu machen,
was ja Overwatch von Anfang an nicht war.
Also, das muss man, das muss man
auch mal klar sagen, Overwatch hatte viele,
äh, Mechaniken drin, die,
die schlicht ergreifend unfair
sind. Wenn ich mir die ganzen
Overtime-Mechaniken am Anfang angucke,
du konntest ne Map verlieren,
obwohl du, ähm,
quasi
mehr Objective-Time
hattest und sowas, das ist so,
ah, ganz, ganz merkwürdig, oder
dann diese komischen
Timings bei 2CP,
wo du dazu
gezwungen warst, jetzt
dich zu wei-, also dich, dich
sterben zu lassen, dein Team, dass du überhaupt ne
Chance hattest, Punkt 2
zu defenden oder umgedreht, dass
du jetzt quasi gar nicht mehr attacken kannst,
weil dir ist einer beim Attack
gestorben und der Defender-Spawn ist
bei Anubis direkt um die Ecke und sowas.
Ich kann nicht wirklich sinnvoll
nachvollziehen, was Blizzard sich bei manchen Sachen gedacht hat.
Äh, schon mitbekommen mit
Ubisoft Montreal, ja, haben wir uns schon angeguckt.
Das letzte, was ich gesehen habe auf Twitter ist, dass
nach das Haus-Evakuieren noch nix passiert ist,
oder was heißt noch nix, das hört sich jetzt so an, als will
ich, dass was passiert, nein, ich will nicht, dass was passiert,
ja, ähm, also es ist nichts
passiert bis jetzt, ich hoffe auch nicht, dass noch was
passiert. Ja, Points waren auch,
es war, es war eklig, ja,
also, es hat sich nicht, es hat sich
in Overwatch leider oftmals so angefühlt,
als wurdest du, äh,
beschissen
vom Game. Und das ist
eigentlich
eines der schlechtesten Sachen,
was du haben kannst bei einem
Competitive Game. Du musst eigentlich,
also, wenn's gut gemacht ist, solltest du
immer das Gefühl haben,
du warst schlecht
und hast deswegen verloren.
Oder du hast an irgendwas nicht gedacht,
oder du hast irgendwas falsch gemacht
und deswegen hast du auf den Sack gekriegt. So sollte
das optimalerweise in, in,
in solchen Games sein, in überwiegenden
Teilen der Fälle. Klar, Bullshit
passiert in jedem Game mal, aber
in Overwatch hast du das Gefühl, dass du
gefühlt jede, jede Runde du
um irgendwas beschissen wurdest, und das kann nicht
sein. Es war nervig mit der Zeit
einfach, äh.
Das haben sie bis heute nicht hingekriegt
und ich habe auch meine Zweifel, dass
auf, dass sie das mit Overwatch 2 hinkriegen.
Ich, ich halte ja persönlich
eh Overwatch 2, dass sie das da ange,
also erstmal für den übelsten Schnellschuss,
ähm,
der auch überhaupt nichts
so aussah, als will man ihn spielen.
Es sah im Prinzip
aus, als hätte sich ne, äh,
ne Gruppe Modder hingesetzt mit nem Map Editor
und versucht,
äh, ein paar Overwatch Singleplayer Missionen
zu designen. So sah der
Trailer zu Overwatch 2 aus.
Also,
nix, was da irgendwie großartig Hype generiert.
Ja, aber wenn man sich anguckt,
die, die Overwatch League ist,
pff, ja, sie gibt sie irgendwie
noch, aber Zuschauerzahlen sind kacke.
Muss ich mal angucken, dass
Overwatch League die letzten Spiele,
letztens so ne Statistik gesehen,
die haben weniger Zuschauer,
als irgendwie so ne 0815
äh, CS Tournament.
Also, ich red jetzt nicht von irgendeinem,
irgendeinem riesen, riesen, äh,
Major, irgendwie
keiner Dreamhack oder so, gibt's eigentlich
Interlex Dreammasters noch? Ne, das war eher StarCraft, ne?
Ähm, davon red
ich ja gar nicht. Sondern von so,
von so normalen, irgendwelchen,
irgendwelchen, frag mich nicht, äh, äh,
äh, Faceit-Dinger
oder sowas, die haben dann 35, 60
K, 35 bis 60.000,
äh, Zuschauer auf,
auf, auf Twitch. Und da hast du teilweise
den offiziellen Overwatch League, das, äh,
quasi das S-Tier, äh,
Level von Overwatch, drunter.
Da denk ich mir halt auch, okay, ähm,
pff,
es kann halt nicht das Ziel sein,
bei ner Liga, die mit so viel Millionen
da finanziert wurde, wo es
Millionen Buy-In kostet,
ähm,
es will keiner sehen im Endeffekt.
Und das ist kein guter Boden für, äh,
großartige Overwatch-Zukunft, ja.
Aber das Blizzard ist meiner Meinung nach
voll selbst dran schuld, ja. Das ist nix, was man
irgendwie auf die Spieler schieben kann.
Fanboys machen das gerne, Fanboys schieben Sachen gerne
auf die, auf die Spieler. So nach dem Motto,
ja, kein Wunder, wenn alle Spieler so toxic sind,
dass das Spiel in den Bach runtergeht.
Nein, der Hersteller muss die Rahmenbedingungen
setzen. Und,
ganz im Ernst,
CS und gerade LOL
ist auch toxic as fuck.
Also man kann das nicht so rein
auf, auf die Spieler. Jedes Competitive
Spiel ist, jedes Competitive
Team-Game ist toxic as fuck im Team.
Untereinander, wenn man nicht regelmäßig
miteinander spielt. Und selbst
Singleplayer-Spiele, äh, nicht Singleplayer,
ähm, äh, One-on-One-Spiele
wird auch oft genug rumgeflamed.
Also, das,
das ist nicht, das ist nicht so in Overwatch.
Ich mein, Overwatch war schon extrem toxic, aber
das Spiel hat auch dazu eingeladen.
Und das hat Blizzard verkackt,
kann man nicht anders sagen.
Ja, Leute, so, ich geh jetzt ins Bett.
22 Uhr 22.
Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream.
Macht's gut, bis denn, CU.